GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE. WELCOME
THE SELECT COMMITTEE. THIS
SELECT COMMITTEE ON SCHOOL
CLIMATE AND STUDENT SAFETY IS
NOW COME TO ORDER, FIRST OF ALL,
I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU WHO
HAVE JOINED HERE IN PERSON. AND,
THE BULK OF OUR PARTICIPATION,
WHICH IS REMOTE, IT ACROSS THE
STATE, THERE'S A NEED. AND SO
MANY OF OUR COLLEAGUES WERE NOT
ABLE TO FLY DOWN HERE. AND SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
WATCHING AT HOME ARE ALSO ABLE
TO, TO LISTEN AND BE ABLE TO
HAVE THE INFORMATION AVAILABLE.
THE LINK WILL REMAIN IN OUR
SOCIAL MEDIA WEB PAGE, FOR
ANYONE THAT NEEDS IT, ONCE
AGAIN, GOOD AFTERNOON AND
WELCOME EVERYONE WHO'S HERE
TODAY. I'M SO HONORED TO HAVE
SUCH ESTEEMED GUEST HERE WITH ME
AS AN EDUCATOR MYSELF FOR 20
YEARS. I UNDERSTAND THE NEED TO
EXPLORE THIS TOPIC, IN LIGHT OF
COVID AND OTHER ISSUES THAT ARE
FACING OUR YOUNG INDIVIDUALS, I
WAS VICE PRINCIPAL FOR THREE
YEARS, WHICH ALSO GAVE ME A MUCH
BROADER PERSPECTIVE OF SOME OF
THE ISSUES FACING OUR CHILDREN.
AND SO, AGAIN, I COULD NOT BE
MORE THANKFUL FOR SUCH AN
INCREDIBLE PANEL THAT WE'VE
ASSEMBLED TO DISCUSS SOME OF THE
MOST PRESSING ISSUES. NOW FACING
OUR OUR CHILDREN, ESPECIALLY AS
IT PERTAINS TO MENTAL HEALTH,
IT'S A VERY CRITICAL ISSUE THAT
NOW REALLY DEMANDS FOR US TO
FOCUS AND, AND SEE WHERE WE CAN
FIND OPPORTUNITIES TO MAKE THIS
BETTER AND OFFER SUPPORT TO OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS, OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS, AND OF COURSE,
PARENTS WHO CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE
AT HOME, SO AS WE NAVIGATE THE
AFTERMATH OF COVID 19, WHICH IS
REALLY WHAT, SOME OF THE BIG
FOCUS OF THIS COMMITTEE IS GOING
TO BE, WHAT ARE WE SEEING IN THE
AFTERMATH? YESTERDAY, I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO A SCHOOL
COUNSELOR WHO SHARED THAT SHE
WAS DEALING WITH A SIX YEAR OLD
WHO IS, SUICIDAL. AND AS WE SEE,
MORE AND MORE, WE'RE SEEING
YOUNGER AND YOUNGER KIDS HAVING
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. AND SO
TODAY, I'M REALLY FOCUSED ON
TRYING TO FIND PREVENTATIVE
MEASURES, PROGRAMS AND SUPPORT,
FOR THOSE THAT NEED IT, SO TODAY
I WANT TO SHARE SOME STATISTICS,
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES ARE
PARTICULARLY MORE EXPOSED TO
SOME OF THESE IMPACTS. FOR
EXAMPLE, 29% OF CHILDREN WITH AN
AUTISM SPECTRUM DISORDER FACE AT
LEAST ONE HEALTH CARE ACCESS
PROBLEM. RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
MANY OF OUR YOUNG POPULATION
WITH AUTISM FACE SIGNIFICANT
BEHAVIORAL CHALLENGES, WITH 25%
OF THEM EXPERIENCING SUICIDAL
IDEATION. FEMALES WITH AUTISM
SUFFER EVEN MORE DISPROPORTIONAL
IMPACTS, AS THEY ARE NINE TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO DIE BY SUICIDE
COMPARED TO THE REST OF THE
POPULATION. AND SO IN THIS
HEARING, THE PURPOSE IS,
SEVERAL, ISSUES THAT WE WANT TO
ADDRESS, BUT IN PARTICULAR, WE
NEED TO SHED LIGHT ON THE
CURRENT STATE OF STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH, IDENTIFY KEY CHALLENGES,
AND EXPLORE POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS
TO MAKE IT BETTER AND SUPPORT
OUR PARENTS IN A MORE SPECIFIC
AND MEANINGFUL WAY, WE WILL BE
ADDRESSING SEVERAL CRUCIAL
ASPECTS OF STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH. TODAY, I'LL BE POSING
QUESTIONS TO OUR SPEAKERS, BUT I
ALSO HOPE THAT IF OUR SPEAKERS,
HAVE IDEAS OR WANT TO
PARTICIPATE AS SOMEBODY ELSE IS
SHARING INFORMATION, PLEASE DO
SO. I THINK IT'S MORE EFFECTIVE
WHEN IT'S INTERACTIVE AND WE GET
TO FULLY EXPLORE THE
CONVERSATION, WE HAVE, OUR FIRST
PANEL WILL CONSIST OF, VERY
IMPORTANT GUESTS, AND THIS GUEST
WILL BE GIVING AN OVERVIEW OF
THE CURRENT MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
FOLLOWING THE COVID 19 PANDEMIC,
PLEASE ALLOW ME TO INTRODUCE
DOCTOR JANINE TOPLIN, WHO IS
PAST PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGISTS AND APPOINTEE TO
THE STATE'S ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
I'M SORRY, COMMISSION ON SPECIAL
EDUCATION. DOCTOR TAPLIN IS A
SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST WHO OVERCAME
PERSONAL LEARNING CHALLENGES TO
PURSUE A DISTINGUISHED CAREER
THAT SPANS NOW 22 YEARS, AND IN
PARTICULAR, IN EDUCATION AND
MENTAL HEALTH. SHE SPECIALIZES
IN BILINGUAL ARMENIAN
ASSESSMENTS, SCHOOL NEUROPSYCH,
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSESSMENTS AND
SHE STRIVES TO ENHANCE STUDENT
SERVICES BY BRIDGING THE GAP
BETWEEN SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND
COMMUNITY RESOURCES. SO PLEASE,
DOCTOR TOPLIN, YOU MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU. AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH, SENATOR, FOR HAVING US
TODAY AND FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
AND SELECT, COMMITTEE MEMBERS AS
WELL, THIS IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO SHARE
THE INFORMATION, I WANT TO I'M
REPRESENTING CASP TODAY AS A
PAST PRESIDENT. THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGIST, WHERE WE HAVE
OVER, 2000 MEMBERS. AND WE ALSO
HAVE LICENSED EDUCATIONAL
PSYCHOLOGISTS, WHERE WE OVERSEE
THE PROFESSION, WHERE WE HAVE
THE ETHICS, THE GUIDELINES OF
WHAT WE DO IN EVERYDAY PRACTICE.
WHO ARE SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGISTS?
SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGISTS ARE HAVE
UNIQUE, SPECIALIZED TRAINING TO
BE ABLE TO BRIDGE THE GAP
BETWEEN PSYCHOLOGY AND
EDUCATION. WE ARE PART OF MENTAL
HEALTH TEAMS. WE ARE PART OF
CRISIS TEAMS. WE WORK WITH
PARENTS. WE COLLABORATE WITH
OUTSIDE AGENCIES. WE HAVE
SPECIALIZED KNOWLEDGE IN, BEING
ABLE TO DO THREAT ASSESSMENTS
AND CRISIS INTERVENTION AND
PROGRAMING AS WELL. AND WE
COLLABORATE WITH OUR OTHER
SCHOOL BASED MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS WHO ARE THE SCHOOL
COUNSELORS, THE SCHOOL SOCIAL
WORKERS AS WELL, TO PROVIDE A
COLLABORATIVE. AND I'M SORRY, I
SHOULD BE MOVING IT ALONG RIGHT.
OH, THERE YOU GO. THERE YOU GO.
SO WE WORK WITH OUR OTHER SCHOOL
BASED MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE A HOLISTIC APPROACH OF
BEING ABLE TO WRAP THE WHOLE
CHILD AROUND FOR MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS TO ACADEMIC NEEDS TO
BEHAVIORAL NEEDS AS WELL, WE
SERVE THE SCHOOL COMMUNITIES AND
WE PROVIDE COUNSELING,
ASSESSMENT, RESEARCH, OUTREACH
PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT AND PROMOTE
SOCIAL JUSTICE, AND MANY OF OUR
SCHOOL BASED MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS HAVE HOLD A
MINIMUM OF A MASTER'S DEGREE AND
A PUPIL PERSONNEL CREDENTIAL,
WHICH YOU NEED TO WORK IN THE
SCHOOLS WHERE IT'S VERY SPECIFIC
OF EDUCATION BASED AS WELL. SO
THE FACT THAT STUDENTS ARE
PROVIDE A PROVIDER RATIO
PROFESSIONAL RECOMMENDATIONS
WHEN YOU SEE THESE NUMBERS IS
OUTRAGEOUS. THE WHAT COULD THEY
ALL SEE IT? OKAY. THE CALIFORNIA
IT SAYS THAT 626 TO 1 IS THE
COUNSELORS RATIO TO
PSYCHOLOGISTS IS 1041 TO 1, AND
SOCIAL WORKERS IS 7308 TO 1.
IT'S OVERWHELMING. ALL OUR
STUDENTS BEING SERVICED BY ONE
SOCIAL WORKER. WHEN THERE'S A
SCHOOL SITE OF 3000 TO 4000
STUDENTS, UNDERFUNDED SCHOOL
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT OUR
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
UNFORTUNATELY, MINORITIES AND
PROMISE STUDENTS HAVE LESS
ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OR ARE LESS LIKELY TO RECEIVE
THE NEEDED CARE. FOSTER YOUTH
AND HOMELESS STUDENTS, WHERE WE
COULD PROVIDE THE MOST STABLE
AND POSITIVE COMPONENT OF THEIR
LIVES, THEY MUST ADAPT TO ABRUPT
CHANGES AND CONSTANT MOBILITY.
SCHOOL BASED MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS WILL PROVIDE THAT
STABILITY FOR THESE STUDENTS,
WHERE THEY'RE ABLE TO
COLLABORATE, WHERE THEY'RE ABLE
TO PROVIDE HEALTHY DEVELOPMENT,
WHICH LEADS TO ACADEMIC SUCCESS.
THEIR INVESTMENT IN EQUITIES,
MANY MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS
FIRST APPEAR IN YOUTH AND YOUNG
ADULTS, WITH 50% OF ALL
CONDITIONS DEVELOPING BY AGE OF
14 AND 75% BY THE AGE OF 24. AS
THE SENATOR MENTIONED, THERE ARE
SIX YEAR OLDS OUT THERE WHO ARE
IN CRISIS TODAY, WHO ARE IN NEED
OF A LOT OF SUPPORT FOR MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS. AND WHAT
BETTER PLACE THAN A SCHOOL WHERE
IT'S A HUB OF THE COMMUNITY TO
PROVIDE THESE SERVICES? THERE'S
NO DOUBT THERE'S A GROWING NEED
AND IT'S BEING UNMET IN THE
SCHOOLS, AND WE NEED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES, PROGRAMS,
COMMUNITY OUTREACH TO BE ABLE TO
SERVE SERVICE THE CHILD
HOLISTICALLY AND WRAP THE CHILD
AROUND INCLUDING THE FAMILIES,
THE PARENTS, THE EXTENDED FAMILY
ITSELF AS WELL, AND WELL
DOCUMENTED IN RESEARCH AS WELL.
WHERE WE SEE THAT IF THEY DON'T
RECEIVE A STUDENTS DO NOT
RECEIVE CHILDREN, THEY DON'T
RECEIVE THE TIMELY INTERVENTIONS
OR PREVENTATIVE WORK, THEN THEY
WILL NOT BE SUCCESSFUL. THEY
WILL NOT THE PIPELINE TO PRISON
WILL INCREASE AS WELL. WE NEED
MORE ACCESS TO EARLY MENTAL
HEALTH SO THEY ACHIEVE THEIR
LIFE GOALS AND THEY CAN SHINE.
INVESTING IN STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORTS HAS FAR REACHING
BENEFITS ON THE SCHOOL SITES.
UNFORTUNATELY, MANY OF THE
SCHOOL BASED MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS ARE OVERWHELMED
WITH A LOT OF THEIR HEAVY
CASELOADS, AND THEY'RE NOT ABLE
TO BE PREVENTATIVE, SO THEY'RE
MORE REACTIVE BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT PAYING ATTENTION TO THOSE
STUDENTS BECAUSE OF THEIR HEAVY
CASELOAD, THE CONTINUUM OF
SERVICES IS NOT BEING UTILIZED
IN A PRODUCTIVE WAY, BUT
RESEARCH HAS DEMONSTRATED,
FORTUNATELY, POSITIVELY,
RESEARCH HAS DEMONSTRATED THAT
HAVING SCHOOL BASED MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS WILL HELP
MAINTAIN THE SCHOOL COMMUNITY
AND THE WELL-BEING OF THE SCHOOL
OF THE OF THE STUDENTS.
PREVENTION HELPS DEMONSTRATE A
LOT OF DIFFERENT POSITIVE SOCIAL
INTERVENTIONS AND ACADEMIC
GROWTH. SUPPORTING STUDENTS.
THERE WAS ONE RESEARCH DONE
WHERE THERE WAS AN APPLICATION
USED, BY STUDENTS, AND IT SHOWED
THAT THE SOCIAL SKILLS
INTERVENTION IN A HIGH POVERTY
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS, WHERE IT
IMPROVED COMMUNICATION, WHERE
THE STUDENTS WERE ABLE TO HAVE
MORE SELF CONTROL, THEY WERE
ABLE TO HAVE MORE
RESPONSIBILITY. THEY'RE
COOPERATIVE AND IMPROVE THEIR
COMMUNICATION. WE NOT ONLY HELP
STUDENTS, BUT WE ALSO HELP
TEACHERS BECAUSE TEACHERS ARE
SET UP FOR FAILURE. WE PROVIDE
THEM. THEY'RE IN THE CLASSROOM
WITH STUDENTS EVERY SINGLE DAY.
THEY ARE THE FIRST LINE OF
DEFENSE, BUT GIVEN THE RESEARCH,
WHEN SCHOOL BASED MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS ARE ON CAMPUS AND
THEY'RE ABLE TO COLLABORATE WITH
THE TEACHERS, IT'S PROVEN THAT
ACADEMIC SUCCESS AND SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL HEALTH OF STUDENTS
IMPROVE. AND WE SUPPORT FAMILIES
AS WELL, WHERE PARENTS WE WORK
WITH PARENTS, GIVING PROVIDING
THEM WORKSHOPS, HOME SCHOOL
PARTNERSHIPS AND COLLABORATIONS
HELP THEM FIND POSITIVE EFFECTS
IN PREVENTING AGGRESSIVE AND
ANTISOCIAL BEHAVIORS IN THEIR
STUDENTS. COLLABORATION IS A IS
A BIG KEY. DURING THE PANDEMIC,
THE SCHOOL BASED MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS CAME TOGETHER AND
WE DRAFTED THIS GUIDING
DOCUMENT, FOSTERING THE WHOLE
CHILD, WHICH IS PART OF YOUR
PACKAGE TODAY. THIS HAS BECOME
OUR GUIDING DOCUMENT NOT ONLY
DURING THE PANDEMIC BUT
THROUGHOUT OUR WORK TODAY,
BECAUSE WE HAVE SEEN THE
IMPORTANCE OF WHAT STUDENTS NEED
AND HOW WE NEED TO HELP THEM
POST PANDEMIC. WITH THE
INCREASED MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS OF
STUDENTS ARE FACING IN THE
SCHOOL SITE, HOW WE COLLABORATE
TOGETHER AND HOW WE WORK
TOGETHER TO SUPPORT THE STUDENTS
WHERE WE TRY TO REDUCE
ATTENDANCE BARRIERS. WE PROVIDE
SKILL DEVELOPMENT, PREPARE FOR
CRISIS, FOSTER A POSITIVE
CLIMATE, SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT, AND WE PROVIDE
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE PRACTICES.
IMPLEMENT MULTI-TIERED SYSTEMS
OF SUPPORT AS WELL. WORKING
TOGETHER FOR A POSITIVE SCHOOL
CLIMATE AND COMMUNITY FOR EVERY
STUDENT IN IN OUR SCHOOLS, ACLU,
THE AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES
UNION, CONDUCTED A STUDY AND HAD
A REPORT IN 2022. AND SOME OF
THE HIGHLIGHTS FROM THIS REPORT
INCLUDE THAT 63% OF STUDENTS
REPORTED EXPERIENCING AN
EMOTIONAL MELTDOWN AND 45% OF
STUDENTS REPORTED FEELING
DEPRESSED. 45% OF OUR STUDENTS.
THAT'S A LOT OF STUDENTS. OVER
HALF OF OUR STUDENTS REPORTED
THE NEED FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES, AND BOTH SURVEYS WITH
OVER 22% OF STUDENTS DESIRING
SERVICES FOR THE FIRST TIME EACH
YEAR. AFTER MORE THAN A YEAR OF
PANDEMIC AND GLOBAL SHUTDOWN IN
2021, SURVEY FOUND ONLY 17% OF
STUDENTS REPORTED AN INCREASE OF
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AT THEIR
SCHOOL SITE AND THAT
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY, 83, DID
NOT EXPERIENCE CHANGE IN ACCESS
TO SERVICES. MENTAL HEALTH SO
WHAT DID THE SCHOOL REPORT, WHAT
WERE SOME OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
THE REPORT FOUND? THEY FOUND
THAT MENTAL HEALTH STRESS AND
ANXIETY WAS HIGH. SOCIAL
DEVELOPMENT WAS STUNTED, FALLING
BEHIND ACADEMICALLY AND
EXHAUSTION AND STRUGGLING TO
MAINTAIN THE TEACHERS PATIENCE
IS WEARING OFF, AND THEY WERE
ABLE TO NOTICE THAT.
INTERESTINGLY, WESTED HAD
CONDUCTED, BASED ON THE REPORT
THEY REPORT THE NATIONAL TRENDS
ON THE KID HEALTHY KIDS. THEY
FOUND THAT NATIONAL TRENDS, THAT
POOR MENTAL HEALTH AND SUICIDAL
THOUGHTS AND BEHAVIORS INCREASED
FROM 2011 TO 2021. HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS REPORTED CHRONIC
SADNESS. HOPELESSNESS INCREASED
FROM 28% AND 2011 TO 42, AND
2021. THOUGHTS OF SUICIDE
INCREASED FROM 16% TO 22, AND
ATTEMPTS OF SUICIDE INCREASED
FROM 8% TO 10. THE NATIONAL
TRENDS ARE NEARLY IDENTICAL TO
TRENDS IN CALIFORNIA FOR CHRONIC
SADNESS AND HOPELESSNESS AND
SUICIDE IDEATIONS. IT'S STABLE,
BUT TOO HIGH IN CALIFORNIA, IT
INCREASED BY US BY FIVE
PERCENTAGE POINTS BETWEEN 2017
AND 2021, ALTHOUGH IN 2022 THE
REPORT INDICATES THAT THERE IS A
DECLINE IN SUICIDAL IDEATIONS,
IT'S STILL RELATIVELY HIGH, SO
WE NEED TO TAKE THOSE THINGS
INTO CONSIDERATION. AND THAT
STUDENTS DID REPORT FEELING LESS
SOCIAL DISTRESS. THEY DID REPORT
FEELING, MORE SOCIAL, AND ALSO
THEY REPORTED MORE OPTIMISM, AND
MORE SATISFACTION. BUT AGAIN,
THE OUTLOOK IS NOT IT'S
RELATIVELY STILL WEAK. WE STILL
HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO AS WE
MOVE FORWARD, BECAUSE OUR
STUDENTS ARE FACING A LOT OF
CHALLENGES OUT IN THE SCHOOLS.
SUSTAINABILITY AND LONGEVITY.
ADDRESSING MENTAL HEALTH. THIS
WAS ANOTHER STUDY BY THE
NATIONAL EDUCATION ASSOCIATION
MEMBERS, AND THEY FOUND THAT
EDUCATORS WERE FACING A LOT OF
STRESS AND BURNOUT, WHICH
INCREASED THE PERCENTAGE. AND
DURING THE PANDEMIC, AND THEY
WERE MORE LIKELY TO LEAVE THE
PROFESSION. MORE THAN HALF, 55%
OF MEMBERS SAY THAT THEY'RE MORE
LIKELY TO LEAVE OR RETIRE
EDUCATION SOONER THAN THEY'RE
PLANNED, AND THAT BLACK AND
HISPANIC EDUCATORS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO SAY THEY'RE MORE
LIKELY TO RETIRE TO LEAVE EARLY,
WHICH COULD LEAVE THE TEACHING
PROFESSION LESS DIVERSE.
EDUCATORS SUPPORT SEVERAL
PROPOSALS TO ADDRESS EDUCATOR
BURNOUT, RAISING EDUCATOR
SALARIES, PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORTS FOR
STUDENTS, HIRING MORE TEACHERS,
MORE SUPPORT STAFF, REDUCING THE
PAPERWORK. SOME OF THE
SUGGESTIONS THAT ACLU MADE WAS,
AGAIN, IT'S NOT NEW. IT'S ABOUT
INCREASING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR YOUTH FUNDING STATE
LEVEL STUDENT LED INITIATIVES,
INCREASING FUNDING FOR SCHOOL
COUNSELORS, SOCIAL WORKERS AND
PSYCHOLOGISTS, AND NURSES,
SUSTAINING THE INCREASED FUNDS
TO COMMUNITY SCHOOLS, CONTINUING
TO INVEST IN SCHOOL COUNTY
PARTNERSHIPS, AND SUPPORTING
HOLISTIC EDUCATION AND WELLNESS
FOR ARTS AND MUSIC. ART DANCE
AND INCREASING OVERSIGHT,
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR DISTRICT
SPENDING. BUT THERE'S POSITIVES
BECAUSE WITH THE MULTI-TIERED
SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT WE RESEARCH
HAS INDICATED THAT THIS IS A
LEVEL THAT HAS WORKED. WHAT ARE
MULTI-TIERED SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT?
THERE ARE DIFFERENT TIERS. THERE
UNIVERSAL TIER TARGETED AND
SPECIFIC. WHERE SCHOOL BASED
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS WORK
TOGETHER COLLABORATIVELY TO
SUPPORT THE WHOLE CHILD.
SCHOOLWIDE POSITIVE BEHAVIOR
SUPPORTS ACROSS THE SCHOOL
SETTING WHERE WE'RE ALL ABLE TO
HELP THE STUDENT BUILD SOCIAL
SKILLS, BE ABLE TO GROW
ACADEMICALLY AND BE ABLE TO
STRIVE FOR HIGHER AND BE ABLE TO
MEET THEIR GOALS. AND WHAT DOES
THAT LOOK LIKE? IT'S A
COMPREHENSIVE RANGE OF SERVICES
WHERE THE STUDENTS THAT NEED THE
MOST IS PREVENTATIVE. THAT'S THE
MOST IMPORTANT MESSAGE I COULD
TELL YOU. IT'S PREVENTATIVE AND
BEING ABLE TO TARGET THE
STUDENTS THAT NEED MORE SPECIFIC,
INTERVENTIONS AT THE DIFFERENT
TIER LEVELS, MENTAL HEALTH WISE.
AND AGAIN, BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE
THESE BEHAVIORAL SUPPORTS AS
WELL, IT'S EVIDENCE BASED WHERE
WE COULD PROVIDE EVIDENCE BASED,
INTERVENTIONS AT THE DIFFERENT
TIERS. UNIVERSAL TIER WHERE
EVERY STUDENT HAS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO BENEFIT FROM THOSE
INTERVENTIONS OR PREVENTATIVE
WORK IN ITSELF. AND STUDENTS,
WHAT WE FIND IN HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS AND POSITIVE
SCHOOL CLIMATE, HEALTHY, HAPPY
STUDENTS EQUATES TO POSITIVE
SCHOOL CLIMATE. WHAT WE FOUND IS
THAT SCHOOL CONNECTEDNESS IS A
POWERFUL PREDICTOR OF ADOLESCENT
HEALTH AND STUDENT MOTIVATION TO
LEARN. THIS IS NOT A NEW CONCEPT
THAT TEACHERS AND PARENTS HAVE
BEEN SAYING OVER MANY YEARS. BUT
SINCE 1958, BUT THINK ABOUT IT,
THAT ONE TEACHER THAT WE ALL HAD
IN SCHOOL, WHO MOTIVATED,
MOTIVATED US TO BE ABLE TO
ATTEND SCHOOL TO BE ABLE TO
CAPTURE US, TO WANT US TO GO
BACK FOR MORE. DON'T OUR
STUDENTS AT SCHOOL DESERVE THIS
RIGHT? TO HAVE A POSITIVE SCHOOL
CLIMATE, TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS
AND HAVE THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES
AND NOT HAVE THE BARRIERS IN
PLACE SO THEY COULD GROW
ACADEMICALLY, SOCIALLY AND
EMOTIONALLY, SO MENTAL HEALTH
PLAYS A CRUCIAL ROLE BUILDING
HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS AND
FOSTERING THESE RELATIONSHIPS,
PROMOTING SUPPORTIVE AND
INCLUSIVE ENVIRONMENTS, AND
HAVING POSITIVE SCHOOL SOCIAL
INTERACTIONS AND HAVING THE
SCHOOLS AND THE STUDENTS COME
BACK TO SCHOOL AND BEING ABLE TO
GROW FROM THERE, HAVING SECURE
AND SUPPORTIVE ENVIRONMENTS. BUT
IT'S NOT ONLY ABOUT THE STUDENTS
AS WELL, IT'S ABOUT THE
TEACHERS. OUR SCHOOL STAFF. WE
NEED TO CONSIDER AS WE ARE
THINKING ABOUT A POSITIVE SCHOOL
CLIMATE, WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT
WHAT HAS WORKED AND WHAT HAS
NOT, AND RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT
STAFF FOCUSED MODEL OF SCHOOL
CLIMATE WORKS. SO, THINKING
ABOUT THE OVERALL WE OFTEN TELL
TEACHERS, OUR STAFF WHAT TO DO.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO THINK
ABOUT ASKING THEM WHAT THEY NEED
AND WHAT THEIR SKILLS, WHERE
THEIR SKILL SET IS. BEFORE WE
IMPLEMENT OR DEVELOP PROGRAMS,
THEY NEED TO BE PART OF THE
PROCESS, RATHER THAN BEING THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THE FRONT LINE
TRYING TO DO THIS WORK FOR OUR
STUDENTS. BECAUSE WHEN WE ALL
WORK COLLABORATIVELY TOGETHER,
WE HAVE HIGHER RATES OF SUCCESS
AND WE'RE ABLE TO MAKE IT MORE
SUCCESSFUL AT THE END. OUR END
GOAL IS TO MAKE THESE STUDENTS
BE ABLE TO GRADUATE AND BE ABLE
TO TRANSITION TO COLLEGE OR,
ADVANCED CAREER GOALS IN ITSELF.
SO WE NEED TO ASK OUR STAFF
MEMBERS. AND THAT'S THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING BEFORE WE DO
ANYTHING. OKAY, SO ADDRESSING
THE MENTAL HEALTH, WHAT HAVE WE
SEEN POST COVID IS MOST
IMPORTANT. WHAT HAS WORKED WITH
OUR STUDENTS AND OUR SCHOOLS?
IT'S AGAIN WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH OUR SCHOOL
TEAM BECAUSE WE CANNOT DO THIS
BY OURSELVES. THERE WILL BE
BURNOUT. WE NEED TO INCORPORATE
THE TEACHERS, THE SCHOOL STAFF
FROM OUR FROM OUR MAINTENANCE
STAFF ALL THE WAY TO OUR
PRINCIPALS TO OUR DISTRICT LEVEL
STAFF TO, TO OUR COUNTY TO
HAVING OUR, YOU KNOW, STATE
LEVEL STAFF BEING ABLE TO ALL
WORK TOGETHER TO COME UP WITH
GOALS BECAUSE WE WILL PEOPLE
WILL BURN OUT, PEOPLE WILL LEAVE
THE FIELD, AND WE WILL HAVE MORE
AND MORE SHORTAGES. AS WE KNOW,
CONSULTING WITH TEACHERS HAS
WORKED, GIVING THEM POSITIVE
INTERVENTIONS, ASKING THEM, WHEN
I WALK INTO A CLASSROOM, I DON'T
TURN AROUND AND ASK IT. I DON'T
TELL THEM WHAT TO DO AS A
TEACHER. I SAY, HEY, HOW COULD I
HELP YOU? WHAT DO YOU NEED RIGHT
NOW? WHAT'S GOING TO WORK FOR
YOU? THAT'S WHAT THE MESSAGE HAS
TO BE CLEAR ASKING INSTEAD OF
TELLING. PROVIDING INFORMATION
TO TEACHERS ABOUT SIGNS OF
DEPRESSION BECAUSE TEACHERS ARE
NOT TRAINED TO SEE ALL OF THIS,
AND THEY'RE TOO BUSY HAVING THE
CURRICULUM THAT THEY NEED TO
PROVIDE FOR THE STUDENTS, IT'S
PUTTING SOMETHING ELSE ON THEIR
TABLE AND HAVING THEM, TO DO IN
THEIR CLASSROOM. WE NEED TO
PROVIDE THEM WITH SOME
GUIDELINES AND HELP AND
ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORTS TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT. AND THAT'S
WORKED. WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO DO
THAT POST PANDEMIC, AND SOME
TEACHERS WILL BE RECEPTIVE. AND
OUR GOAL IS HOW DO WE EMPOWER
THEM? CONSULTING WITH TEACHERS,
ADMINISTRATORS TO DEVELOP
APPROPRIATE RESPONSES AND
CULTURALLY RESPONSES. THAT'S THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING, IS HOW DO
WE RESPOND CULTURALLY AND BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES?
IF I'M NOT ABLE TO PROVIDE IT
CULTURALLY, THEN THEY WILL.
WHERE TO GO TO FIND THOSE
SERVICES IN THE COMMUNITY, IN
THE SCHOOL SITE, VISITING
CLASSROOMS, MONITORING AND ALSO
MONITORING AND CHECKING IN WITH
THE TEACHERS AND BEING ABLE TO
HELP THEM. PROVIDING THREAT
ASSESSMENTS WHEN WARRANTED,
STRUGGLING WITH ISSUES, AND THEN
PROVIDING REFERRALS TO STAFF AND
COMMUNITY AGENCIES AS WARRANTED.
AGAIN, OFFERING TO FACILITATE
FACILITATE PARENT TRAININGS
BECAUSE PARENTS ARE NOT ALWAYS
WELL EQUIPPED, THEY MAY BE TOO
BUSY HAVING TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
AND THEY'RE WORKING. THEY'RE NOT
ALWAYS AROUND THEIR CHILDREN, SO
PROVIDING THEM SOME OF THE
SIGNS, HAVING OPPORTUNITIES,
PROVIDING DIFFERENT THINGS
DURING DIFFERENT TIMES OF DAY,
MORNING, NIGHT, AFTERNOONS WHEN
THEY'RE AVAILABLE ON WEEKENDS,
MAYBE ASSISTING IN DEVELOPING
AND ENHANCING THE SCHOOL WIDE
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORTS,
REFERRING STUDENTS TO OUTSIDE
AGENCIES BECAUSE THERE'S SO
MUCH, AGAIN, WITHIN OUR SCOPE,
WITHIN THE SCHOOL SETTING AND
HAVING THAT COMMUNITY SUPPORT
AND WORKING COLLABORATIVELY
TOGETHER AND MEETING WITH
PARENTS TO DISCUSS STUDENT NEEDS
AND CONSULTING AGAIN, WITH ALL
THE DIFFERENT LEVELS AND HAVING
TRAUMA INFORMED CARE. SO WHAT
ARE SOME OF THE KEY INSIGHTS
TEAM APPROACH WITH OTHER SCHOOL
BASED MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS
AND OF COURSE, THE STUDENT VOICE
FROM THE ACLU WHERE I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ATTEND IN JUNE
LAST YEAR IN LOS ANGELES TO MEET
WITH THE STUDENTS. IT WAS VERY
IMPORTANT TO HEAR WHAT THEY
NEED, WHAT THEY WANT, AS WHEN
WE'RE ASKING THE TEACHERS, WE
NEED TO LISTEN TO THE STUDENTS
AS WELL. THE STUDENTS VOICE
MATTERS. IT'S THEIR SELF REPORT.
WE NEED TO LISTEN TO WHAT
STUDENTS WANT AND AGAIN CONTINUE
UTILIZING THE MULTI-TIERED
SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT FRAMEWORK
BECAUSE IT'S WORKING. EVEN
THOUGH IT'S NOT AHEAD OF WHERE
WE WANT TO BE, BUT IT'S STILL
WORKING. IT'S GIVING US SOME
SUPPORTS IN THE SCHOOLS AND
AGAIN, FUNDING SCHOOL BASED
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS TO
BE ABLE TO TRIAGE, TO WORK
TOGETHER, TO PROVIDE THE TIMELY,
EFFECTIVE MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORTS
FOR ALL OUR STUDENTS AND OUR IN
OUR SCHOOL STAFF AS WELL. AND
ALSO, I SHOULD ADD THAT
TELEPRACTICE OR TELEHEALTH IS
ANOTHER THING THAT HAS WORKED
FOR STUDENTS WITH WHO ARE NOT
ABLE TO ATTEND TO SCHOOL, WHICH
HAS GIVEN THEM SOME WAY OF
TRANSITIONING BACK TO CAMPUSES.
STUDENTS WHO ARE CHRONICALLY,
MEDICALLY FRAGILE, WITH STUDENTS
WHO HAVE SOCIAL ANXIETIES AND
THEY CANNOT. NOW WE HAVE THE
OPTION OF PROVIDING THIS
TELEHEALTH, WHICH HAS HELPED
WITH A LOT OF THOSE BARRIERS IN
THE SCHOOL SITE. SO AGAIN, THESE
ARE SOME RESOURCES IN YOUR
PACKET. AND YOU GUYS COULD
ACCESS. THANK YOU, IF YOU GUYS
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS PLEASE REACH
OUT. I'M AVAILABLE. AND THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY. AGAIN
THANK YOU. DOCTOR TOPILIN,
BEFORE I MOVE FORWARD, I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE AUDIENCE
KNOWS THAT AFTER WE CONCLUDE
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE, A COMMENT
TIME. AND IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS, WRITE THEM DOWN.
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO COME
UP TO THE MICROPHONE AND ADDRESS
THE QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE, BUT
WE'LL HOLD OFF TO THE END UNTIL
WE'RE ABLE TO GET THROUGH ALL
OUR PANELS. BUT JUST AS A RECAP
AND WHAT I HEARD RIGHT NOW IS,
YOU KNOW, REALLY IMPORTANT
INFORMATION. SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT. BUT I GUESS WHAT I'M
TAKING AWAY FROM THIS IS, NUMBER
ONE, WE NEED TO AVOID TO BE
REACTIVE AND MORE PROACTIVE IN
TERMS OF PROVIDING SUPPORT, WE
NEED TO BE MORE TARGETED IN OUR
APPROACH TO INTERVENTION. MORE
SPECIFICALLY, GEARED TOWARDS
THAT INDIVIDUAL. AND NUMBER
THREE, PROMOTING SUPPORTIVE,
INCLUSIVE AND SAFE ENVIRONMENTS
AND WE OFTEN THINK OF THAT AS,
AS IT PERTAINS TO THE STUDENT,
BUT WE DON'T NECESSARILY ALWAYS
FOCUS ON THE TEACHERS,
ADMINISTRATORS BECAUSE THEY ALSO
HAVE, TO BE SUPPORTED. AND I
KNOW PERSONALLY, THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC, I HAD A LOT OF
COLLEAGUES WHO RETIRED, IT WAS
OVERWHELMING. THEY DID NOT WANT
TO DO THE JOB. AND WE WERE OFTEN
THINKING ABOUT THE STUDENTS, BUT
NOT NECESSARILY THOSE THAT ARE
TEACHING IN THE CLASSROOM. SO I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THAT, I
WANT TO MOVE OVER TO OUR NEXT
PANEL. THAT'S OUR PANEL NUMBER
TWO. AND AGAIN, CONTINUE TO
WRITE YOUR QUESTIONS. WE'RE
GOING TO ASK YOU TO COME UP TO
THE DAIS AND ADDRESS THOSE
QUESTIONS FOR YOU. OUR NEXT
PANEL, IS AGAIN A REALLY
INCREDIBLE LEADERS HERE WHO ARE
GOING TO, ADDRESS MITIGATING
FACTORS. AND, HOW WE CAN HELP TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE MENTAL HEALTH
OF OUR STUDENTS AND ADDRESS THE
DECLINE AS IT PERTAINS TO AFTER
THE PANDEMIC AS WELL. FIRST, WE
HAVE WITH US JONATHAN MANNIX,
WHO IS A LICENSED CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKER, WHO IS A SERVICE
PROVIDER HERE IN THE SANGRO
VALLEY. HE OFFERS SUPPORT AND
RESOURCES TO ADULTS AND CHILDREN
EXPOSED TO TRAUMATIC
EXPERIENCES, PARTICULARLY SEXUAL
VIOLENCE AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
HE HAS ALSO COLLABORATED WITH
LOS ANGELES COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
CHILDREN AND FAMILY SERVICES,
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION, TRAINING PARENTS AND
SERVICE PROVIDERS HELPING TO
ADDRESS ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES. AGAIN HERE IN
THE SANGRO VALLEY AND KEARNEY
IS, WITH THE YWCA OF SANGRO
VALLEY. SO I'LL TURN IT OVER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE. THANK YOU. WELCOME. THANK
YOU FOR, ALLOWING THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK HERE,
SENATOR, SO I JUST HAVE SOME
TALKING POINTS THAT I'LL BE
GOING OVER, AS SHE SHARED, I'M
COMING FROM MORE OF THAT
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
PERSPECTIVE, SO REALLY HOPING
JUST TO OFFER SOME INSIGHTS FROM
WHAT I'VE SEEN, PROVIDING
SERVICES IN THE COMMUNITY, IS A
SLIDE DECK READY? TRYING TO
ADVANCE. JOHNNY. BUT I COULD
KEEP GOING, WHILE THEY WORK ON
THAT, SO I JUST HAVE SOME KIND
OF THREE AREAS THAT I WANTED TO
ADDRESS TODAY, FIRST, LIKE I
SAID, LOOKING AT THE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION PERSPECTIVE
ON YOUTH AND MENTAL HEALTH, AND
THEN ALSO LOOKING AT SCHOOL
BASED SERVICES, WHICH THANK YOU
FOR ALL OF THAT INFORMATION,
DOCTOR. REALLY HELPFUL AND
INSIGHTFUL, BUT THEN ALSO
LOOKING AT, AN INITIATIVE WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON, REALLY A PILOT
PROGRAM, SOCIAL MEDIA HARM
REDUCTION AND SOCIAL MEDIA,
FIRST AID, KIND OF LOOKING AT
ADDRESSING THAT IMPACT ON YOUTH
AND MENTAL HEALTH, SO I'LL KEEP
GOING HERE, SO FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE. SO WE JUST HAD A
MEETING THIS WEEK, ACTUALLY,
BECAUSE WHAT'S HAPPENING OR FROM
WHAT I'M HEARING FROM OTHER
PROVIDERS, ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT
ARE ON THE SCHOOL CAMPUSES,
THERE IS, YOU KNOW, THIS KIND OF
OVERWHELMING CASELOAD RIGHT NOW
AND SO THEY'RE NOT ALWAYS ABLE
TO MEET THE NEEDS, ESPECIALLY IF
THEY'RE HIGH RISK REFERRALS. AND
SO A LOT OF THOSE YOU KNOW, AS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE IMPACT
OF THE PANDEMIC, SOME OF IT IS
SOCIAL ISOLATION. YOU KNOW, A
LOT OF US, NOT ONLY CHILDREN,
BUT ADULTS AS WELL. WE BECAME A
LOT MORE ISOLATED. AND SO NOW
THAT WE'RE ALL REINTEGRATING
BACK INTO SOCIAL SPACES, A LOT
OF TIMES IT'S NOT AS EASY TO
CONNECT. AND SO THAT
CONNECTEDNESS THAT
BELONGINGNESS, ISN'T ALWAYS
THERE, SO SOMETIMES THAT'S A
PRESENTING CHALLENGE FOR THE,
YOU KNOW, SUICIDAL BEHAVIOR,
SUICIDAL IDEATIONS. IS THAT JUST
BEING SOCIALLY ISOLATED? BUT
ALSO THERE IS AN INCREASE IN
SUBSTANCE INDUCED PSYCHOSIS. SO
RIGHT NOW A LOT OF YOUTH ARE,
YOU KNOW, TURNING TO SUBSTANCES
TO COPE, PARTICULARLY THC. AND,
YOU KNOW, NOWADAYS YOU CAN GET A
CARTRIDGE AND THE CONCENTRATION
LEVEL IS A LOT HIGHER THAN IT
USED TO BE FOR, YOU KNOW, I
GUESS YOU COULD SAY TRADITIONAL
MARIJUANA OR FLOWER. AND SO A
LOT OF CLINICIANS I'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH, YOU KNOW, THEY
SPEAK TO THAT, THAT THE YOUTH
DON'T KNOW THAT HISTORY OF
MARIJUANA AND HOW IT'S CHANGED
HERE IN OUR COUNTRY. AND SO
BECAUSE OF THAT, THEY'RE KIND OF
OVERINDULGING AND GOING INTO
PSYCHOSIS. SO THOSE TYPE OF HIGH
RISK, YOU KNOW, HIGH REFERRALS,
A LOT OF TIMES THE SCHOOL SYSTEM
IS NOT ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE THOSE
NEEDS. AND SO THEY WILL BE
REFERRED OUT TO PSYCHIATRIC
HOSPITAL OR SOMETIMES A
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION.
AND SO I BRING UP THE MEETING I
WAS IN THIS WEEK, BECAUSE WE
HAVE A BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROGRAM
AT THE YWCA OF SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY. BEFORE I GO ON, I GUESS
I SHOULD HAVE SAID WE ALSO HAVE
A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PROGRAM,
SENIOR SERVICE PROGRAM, AND
YOUTH SERVICES. SO WE DO A LOT.
WE'RE MULTI-SERVICE AGENCY. AND
SO WE'RE AN EXAMPLE OF AN AGENCY
THAT WE DO OFFER BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. BUT WE DON'T HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO TAKE HIGH RISK.
CASES LIKE THAT. AND SO
SOMETIMES, YOU KNOW, YOU MIGHT
LOOK FOR FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES,
AND I'M USING DM AS AN EXAMPLE.
AND SOMETIMES THE AMBIVALENCE
THERE IS, YOU KNOW, WE DON'T
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO TAKE ON A
CONTRACT OF THAT CALIBER AND
REALLY STAY COMPLIANT, SO I
THINK THAT'S A CHALLENGE, YOU
KNOW, TO MEET THE NEED OF MENTAL
HEALTH IS THAT SOME OF THE
SERVICE PROVIDERS ARE WILLING,
THEY JUST MIGHT NOT HAVE THE
CAPACITY, TO TAKE ON THOSE TYPE
OF HIGH RISK CLIENTS OR RECEIVE
THE FUNDING THAT COULD HELP THEM
DELIVER THOSE TYPE OF SERVICES.
AND THEN THAT KIND OF MOVES YOU
INTO MAYBE THERE'S A FEE FOR
SERVICE OPTION, OR MAYBE THERE'S
AN INSURANCE OPTION. BUT A LOT
OF THE FAMILIES, YOU KNOW,
EITHER THEY CAN'T AFFORD IT OR
THEY'RE UNINSURED. AND SO I
THINK THAT STILL CREATES A GAP
RIGHT NOW. AND MEETING THE NEED,
AND THEN THAT KIND OF TAKES ME
TO TALKING ABOUT STIGMA AROUND
MENTAL HEALTH, SO I'VE BEEN
DOING A LOT OF WORK THROUGHOUT
THE CITIES IN THE SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY. THERE'S A LOT OF
DIFFERENT ONES. AND,
PARTICULARLY IN AZUSA, I WAS
RUNNING INTO THAT CULTURAL
CHALLENGE OF, NOT, YOU KNOW, THE
FULL FAMILY BEING OPEN TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES. AND
SO SOMETIMES YOU HAVE FAMILIES
THAT ARE INTERGENERATIONAL
WITHIN THE HOME. AND SO ALTHOUGH
YOUTH, SEEM TO BE A LOT MORE
OPEN TO MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES,
SOMETIMES IT'S THE OLDER ADULTS
IN THE FAMILY THAT MIGHT STILL
BE AMBIVALENT TO ENGAGE WITH THE
SYSTEM. SO I THINK THAT'S
ANOTHER UNIQUE CHALLENGE THAT IN
THE SAN GABRIEL VALLEY, BEING AS
DIVERSE AS IT IS, WE DO HAVE A
LOT OF INTERGENERATIONAL
FAMILIES. AND SO SOMETIMES THAT
CREATES A BARRIER TO,
PARTICULARLY YOUTH ACCESSING THE
SERVICES THAT ARE AVAILABLE, I
WAS DOING SOME WORK AT A YOUTH
AND FAMILY CENTER AGAIN IN
AZUSA, AND I COULD SEE THE, THE
CHALLENGE, YOU KNOW, FOR THE
YOUTH TO HEAR THE INFORMATION
AND MAYBE WANT TO MOVE IN THAT
DIRECTION. BUT WHEN THEY WOULD
GO HOME AND HAVE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS, THEY WOULD KIND OF
COME BACK WITH A NO, THANK YOU.
SO A LOT OF TIMES SOMETIMES IT'S
THAT CULTURAL PIECE THERE, AND
THEN THERE'S ALSO, YOU KNOW, THE
REALITY THAT YOUTH DON'T ALWAYS
HAVE SPACES TO WHERE THEY CAN
HAVE THEIR VOICES HEARD OR EVEN
JUST CONNECT WITH EACH OTHER. SO
THAT'S SOMETHING I WOULD
RECOMMEND, YOU KNOW, IS HOW ARE
WE CREATING THESE SPACES WHERE
YOUTH CAN BE HEARD? AND LIKE I
SAID, ARE THERE YOUTH ADVISORY
OPPORTUNITIES, ONE OF OUR
PROGRAMS RIGHT NOW ARE, THE
TRAUMA PREVENTION PROGRAM, AND
WE HAVE A YOUTH ADVISORY BOARD.
AND SO THAT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT
PIECE, YOU KNOW, ALLOWING THEM
TO COME IN AND TALK ABOUT WHAT
THEY'RE SEEING AMONGST THEIR
PEERS. SO THAT'S KIND OF THE
COMMUNITY BASED PERSPECTIVE
RIGHT NOW ON YOUTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH. BUT I'LL KEEP GOING. SO
SCHOOL BASED SERVICES, AS DOCTOR
THOMPSON MENTIONED, THERE IS
THAT PUPIL PERSONNEL SERVICE
CERTIFICATION. SO A LOT OF TIMES
IF YOU'RE NOT ALREADY WORKING IN
THAT SCHOOL BASED SYSTEM, YOU'RE
NOT, YOU KNOW, REALLY SEEING
THOSE TYPE OF CLIENTS, SO
SOMETHING THAT, YOU KNOW, I'M
THINKING IS A GOOD
RECOMMENDATION IS TO INCREASE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AROUND
HELPING PROFESSIONALS. I KNOW
WHEN I WAS COMING UP THROUGH
COLLEGE OR EVEN IN HIGH SCHOOL,
I DID NOT THINK ABOUT SOCIAL
WORK OR MENTAL HEALTH, BUT I
THINK THAT'S AN INITIATIVE THAT
MAYBE THAT COULD DOWN THE ROAD,
YOU KNOW, HELP INCREASE THOSE
ROLES, BECAUSE IT SOUNDS LIKE
THAT IS A HUGE PROBLEM, RIGHT?
THERE'S A SHORTAGE OF THESE
PROFESSIONALS THAT HAVE THE
QUALIFICATIONS AND THE
CERTIFICATIONS. SO I THINK
LOOKING AT THAT NEXT GENERATION
OF WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
INITIATIVE WOULD BE A REALLY
GREAT, DIRECTION TO GO. AND THEN
I DID WANT TO TALK ABOUT
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS, THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT AGAIN, AND AS YOU
SAID, THE INITIATIVE WE'RE
WORKING ON IS ALL IN FOR AZUSA.
AND IT'S AN INTEGRATED CARE
MODEL OR COLLABORATIVE CARE
MODEL. I'VE HEARD IT CALLED BOTH.
AND ESSENTIALLY YOU JUST WANT TO
CREATE AN EASY ACCESS POINT FOR
FAMILIES IN THE COMMUNITY. SO
SOMETIMES IT MIGHT BE BASED OUT
OF A YOUTH AND FAMILY CENTER, OR
OF A SCHOOL DISTRICT. BUT THE
POINT IS TO BRING TOGETHER
DIFFERENT PROVIDERS. YOU KNOW,
YOU MIGHT HAVE A MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDER, YOU MIGHT HAVE A
MEDICAL PROVIDER, A DENTAL
PROVIDER, EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES,
BUT YOU BRING THEM ALL INTO ONE
LOCATION. SO THAT FAMILIES, YOU
KNOW, AS THEY ARE SENDING THEIR
CHILDREN TO SCHOOL, THEY COULD
GET ALL OF THOSE. IT'S ALMOST
LIKE A WRAPAROUND FOR THE
COMMUNITY, RIGHT? WHERE YOU HAVE
ALL OF THEM KIND OF CONSOLIDATED
INTO ONE CENTRAL LOCATION. SO I
THINK THAT'S A REALLY, EFFECTIVE
MODEL THAT I'VE SEEN YOU KNOW,
THAT HAS A LOT OF PROMISE. SO I
DID WANT TO KEEP GOING INTO
LOOKING AT, YOU KNOW, TEACHERS
AND SO I HAVE FOUR OLDER
SISTERS. AND ONE OF MY
FAVORITES, SHE'S, SHE'S A
ADMINISTRATOR. AND SO WE TALK A
LOT. AND, YOU KNOW, SHE TELLS ME
ABOUT THE CHALLENGES THEY HAVE
ON THEIR CAMPUSES. AND I KNOW
THAT TEACHERS ARE ALREADY KIND
OF OVERBURDENED WITH TRYING TO
MANAGE CLASSROOMS, TRYING TO
LEARN MORE EMOTIONAL
INTELLIGENCE AND ALL THESE
THINGS. BUT OFTENTIMES, I HEAR
THE RECOMMENDATION FOR MORE
MANDATORY TRAINING FOR TEACHERS,
PARTICULARLY AROUND MENTAL
HEALTH, SO MENTAL HEALTH FIRST
AID IS A GREAT OPTION IF YOU
HAVEN'T ALREADY TAKEN THAT
TRAINING. IT'S A TRAIN. THE
TRAINER PROGRAM. AND, I WAS VERY
IMPRESSED. YOU KNOW, WHEN I TOOK
IT, SO I THINK THAT'S A WAY TO
GO IS LOOKING AT MAKING SURE
TEACHERS ARE GETTING THAT
EXPOSURE TO TRAINING, AND AGAIN,
I, I SAY THAT CAUTIOUSLY BECAUSE
I DON'T WANT TO OVERBURDEN
TEACHERS. I THINK IT'S A REALLY
DIFFICULT JOB TO HAVE RIGHT NOW,
AND A LOT OF THAT YOU KNOW, I
THINK THAT COMES WITH ARE THERE
ADDITIONAL SKILLS THAT ARE
NEEDED TO MANAGE THESE CHANGING
CLASSROOM DYNAMICS? BUT AGAIN,
THERE'S A HIGH RATE OF BURNOUT,
AS DOCTOR SHARED EARLIER. SO I
THINK THERE'S A SLIPPERY SLOPE
THERE WITH REQUIRING, YOU KNOW,
TEACHERS TO GET MORE MENTAL
HEALTH TRAINING. BUT I THINK A
GOOD OPTION IS MENTAL HEALTH
FIRST AID, WHICH IS ALSO WHERE
SOCIAL MEDIA FIRST AID COMES IN,
BECAUSE THAT'S ANOTHER HUGE
FACTOR RIGHT NOW WITH YOUTH AND
MENTAL HEALTH IS LOOKING AT HOW
SOCIAL MEDIA IS IMPACTING THEM.
AND I YOU KNOW, I THINK A LOT OF
FOLKS NOWADAYS ARE FOLLOWING
WHAT'S HAPPENING AROUND
LEGISLATION AND DIFFERENT POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR MENTAL
HEALTH AND SOCIAL MEDIA. AND YOU
CAN THINK ABOUT, LIKE THE RECENT
CELL PHONE BAN AS AN EXAMPLE.
AND ALTHOUGH, YOU KNOW,
PROHIBITING USE LIKE THAT COULD
BE EFFECTIVE, A LOT OF TIMES IT
CAN CREATE RESISTANCE. AND SO
SOME OF THE THOUGHT THERE IS,
HOW DO WE KIND OF MEET PEOPLE
WHERE THEY ARE, AND A LOT OF
THAT CAN COME FROM LOOKING AT
HARM REDUCTION. AND IF YOU DON'T
KNOW ABOUT HARM REDUCTION, IT'S
A SUBSTANCE USE APPROACH WHERE
YOU REALLY WANT TO TRY TO FIND
HEALTHIER WAYS TO REDUCE THE
HARM, IT'S KIND OF KNOWING
SOMETIMES IT'S NOT REALISTIC TO
EXPECT PEOPLE TO JUST GO
COMPLETELY ABSTINENT OR TO
COMPLETELY STOP USING A
SUBSTANCE OR IN THIS CASE,
SOCIAL MEDIA, SO SOCIAL MEDIA
FIRST AID IS ESSENTIALLY
DESIGNED TO UPLIFT THOSE SOCIAL
MEDIA HARM REDUCTION
PERSPECTIVES, WHICH LEADS TO
SUSTAINABILITY. YOU KNOW, WHEN
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT SYSTEMS
CHANGE, THESE ARE THINGS THAT
ARE GOING TO TAKE YEARS. AND, A
LOT OF TIMES IT'S ABOUT FINDING
A PROGRAM THAT CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED AND INTEGRATED INTO
CURRICULUM, AGAIN, WITHOUT OVER
OVERLOADING THE EDUCATOR OR THE
ADMINISTRATORS. BUT I'LL GET
INTO SOCIAL MEDIA HARM REDUCTION
A LITTLE BIT MORE. SO LIKE I
SHARED, IT REALLY IS TAKING SOME
PAGES OUT OF HARM REDUCTION,
WHICH YOU CAN THINK ABOUT
SMOKING CESSATION PROGRAMS OR
EVEN LIKE SEATBELTS. RIGHT.
THERE'S THINGS IN OUR SOCIETY
THAT THEY'VE BEEN INTRODUCED TO
REDUCE THE HARM. THEY DON'T
ALWAYS 100, YOU KNOW, LEAD TO A
STOPPAGE OF USE, BUT IT HELPS
PROMOTE HEALTHIER USE. AND SO
YOU CAN THINK ABOUT LIKE A CLEAN
NEEDLE PROGRAM, WHICH SOME
PEOPLE HAVE OPPOSITION TO, THAT,
YOU KNOW, WHERE THEY FEEL LIKE,
HEY, YOU'RE KIND OF ENCOURAGING
THEM TO USE SUBSTANCES. IT'S
MORE LIKE I SAID, MEETING THEM
WHERE THEY ARE, KNOWING THAT
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO STOP. SO
HOW DO WE PROVIDE RESOURCES THAT
ARE GOING TO HELP THEM REDUCE,
YOU KNOW, THE LIKELIHOOD THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO SPREAD DISEASE,
SO SOCIAL MEDIA HARM REDUCTION
IS KIND OF COMING FROM THAT
PERSPECTIVE WHERE WE WANT TO
HELP ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE'S
BENEFITS AND CONSEQUENCES TO
USING SOCIAL MEDIA. AND, THIS IS
A PROGRAM THAT WE PILOTED OUT OF
THE YOUTH AND FAMILY CENTER IN
AZUSA. AND SO IT STARTED AS ONE
OF THE FIVE SUPPORT GROUP TOPICS
THAT I WAS FACILITATING. BUT IT
HAS TURNED INTO MORE OF A
CURRICULUM NOW, WHICH, LIKE I
SAID, IS A SOCIAL MEDIA FIRST
AID. AND SO THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO PILOT
WITH THE LA COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH, RECENTLY,
ACTUALLY. SO IN JUNE AND MAY, WE
DID THEY HAVE THEIR PUBLIC
HEALTH AMBASSADOR PROGRAM. AND
SO WE PARTNERED WITH THEM AND
FACILITATED WORKSHOPS FOR
PARENTS, YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
PROFESSIONALS. AND SO WE'VE ALSO
DONE SOME WORKSHOPS, OTHER
PLACES IN THE SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY, LIKE IN PASADENA, THAT'S
WHERE WE WERE ABLE TO WORK WITH
64 STUDENTS AT BLAIR HIGH SCHOOL
AND DO A WORKSHOP ON SOCIAL
MEDIA, FIRST AID. WE ALSO DID A
WORKSHOP FOR 15 PARENTS AT
GLADSTONE MIDDLE SCHOOL, SO IT
KIND OF HAS THAT MULTIFACETED
APPROACH WHERE WE KNOW STUDENTS,
YOU KNOW, COULD BENEFIT FROM
PSYCHOEDUCATION AROUND SOCIAL
MEDIA. WE KNOW PARENTS ARE ALSO
LOOKING FOR INFORMATION ON
SOCIAL MEDIA. AND THEN AS WELL
AS PROFESSIONALS. AND SO A LOT
OF IT, LIKE I SAID, IS A
COMBINATION OF HARM REDUCTION,
PSYCHOEDUCATION AND THE APPROACH
OF MENTAL HEALTH FIRST AID. SO
MENTAL HEALTH FIRST AID IS NOT A
PROGRAM DESIGNED TO HELP YOU
TREAT MENTAL HEALTH. THEY
RECOGNIZE THAT EVERYONE IS NOT,
YOU KNOW, CLINICAL PROFESSIONAL.
BUT CAN YOU AT LEAST RECOGNIZE
THE RISK? CAN YOU AT LEAST
RECOGNIZE THE SIGNS OF A MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS OR SITUATION AND
THEN REFER THEM TO THE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF CARE?
SOCIAL MEDIA FIRST AID IS
DESIGNED TO DO THAT SAME THING
WHERE WE KNOW THAT SOCIAL MEDIA
IS IMPACTING PEOPLE IN A LOT OF
DIFFERENT WAYS. SO A REALLY BIG
CENTRAL DESIGN COMPONENT OF
SOCIAL MEDIA, FIRST AID IS THE
WHOLE SELF REALLY RESONATED WITH
THE WHOLE CHILD. I THINK WHEN
YOU LOOK AT A PERSON
BIOLOGICALLY, PSYCHOLOGICALLY,
SOCIALLY, SPIRITUALLY,
CULTURALLY, THERE'S A LOT OF
DIFFERENT WAYS THAT THEY COULD
BE IMPACTED. SO A LOT OF THE
PSYCHOEDUCATION AND SOCIAL MEDIA
FIRST AID IS LOOKING AT ALL THE
DIFFERENT WAYS THAT SOCIAL MEDIA
MIGHT IMPACT THE PERSON, BUT
ALSO HELPING REDUCE THE
BYSTANDER EFFECT, WHERE IF YOU
DO RECOGNIZE SOMEONE IS BEING
CHALLENGED WITH SOCIAL MEDIA,
HOW DO YOU THEN CONNECT THEM TO
SUPPORT AND RESOURCES? YOU KNOW,
TO HELP THEM MOVE IN THAT
HEALTHIER DIRECTION OR REDUCE
THAT HARM. SO I RECOMMEND THAT
AGAIN, AS I THINK THAT'S A
PROMISING PILOT THAT WE'VE SEEN.
AND THERE SEEMS TO BE SOME
TRACTION FOR IT. BUT GOING BACK
TO THE REALITY OF HOW SERVICE
WORKS, WHERE YOU NEED TO HAVE AN
EVIDENCE BASE, YOU KNOW,
PERSPECTIVE. AND SO THERE'S
STILL A NEED FOR RESEARCH.
THERE'S STILL A NEED FOR MORE
FUNDING AROUND THIS. BUT I DO
THINK MOVING FORWARD, YOU KNOW,
SOCIAL MEDIA IS KIND OF HERE FOR
NOW. AND IT'S CAUSING A LOT OF
CHALLENGES. SO I WOULD REALLY
HOPE THAT WE CAN FIND WAYS TO
GET THIS INTEGRATED INTO
SCHOOLS, SO THAT STUDENTS ARE
GETTING A MORE CONSISTENT
EXPOSURE TO IT AND STARTING TO
REDUCE SOME OF THOSE HARMS. I
THINK THAT'S ALL I HAVE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH, THERE'S
A LOT OF INFORMATION HERE, AND I
ALWAYS LIKE TO, FOR AT LEAST FOR
MYSELF, SEE WHAT I CAN TAKE AWAY
FROM THESE DISCUSSIONS. AND I'M
HEARING A LOT OF THE, THE KEY
POINTS THAT I HEARD FOR MYSELF
IS JUST THE NEED TO EDUCATE
TEACHERS. AND I CANNOT HELP BUT
THINK OF MY OWN EXPERIENCE. YOU
KNOW, WE'RE NOT MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS, AND YET WHEN
YOU'RE IN A CLASSROOM AND YOU
HAVE A CHILD THAT HAS A CRISIS,
YOU DON'T KNOW HOW TO HANDLE IT.
BUT YET WE'RE EXPECTED TO HANDLE
IT. AND I'VE DONE MANY OF THOSE.
AND YOU DON'T NECESSARILY THINK
OF THE, AN EFFECT THAT'S NOT
QUANTIFIABLE OR WE CANNOT PUT
OUR FINGER ON IT. AND THAT IS
THE IMPACT TO OTHER STUDENTS. I
THINK I HEARD DOCTOR, TOPILIN
SAY EARLIER TODAY, YOU KNOW, WE
HAVE CHILDREN WITH MELTDOWNS.
WELL, WHAT HAPPENS WHEN SOMEONE
HAS A MELTDOWN IN THE CLASS
WHERE THINKING AND FOCUSING ON
THE CHILD WITH THE CRISIS, BUT
YET WE DON'T THINK OF THE 24, 25
KIDS WE HAVE TO ABANDON IN ORDER
TO FOCUS ON THAT ONE CHILD. SO
WE ARE ALSO IMPACTING THOSE THAT
DON'T HAVE ANY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ISSUES. AND SO THE EDUCATION FOR
TEACHER IS KEY, AT LEAST HELPING
THEM TO RECOGNIZE THE CRISIS,
HELPING THEM WITH RESOURCES SO
THEY CAN DEAL WITH THE ISSUES AS
THEY COME. THE OTHER PART IS THE
EDUCATION FOR PARENTS, YOU KNOW,
THEIR ORDINARY CITIZENS JUST
STRUGGLING TO PUT FOOD ON THE
TABLE AND TAKE CARE OF THEIR
HOUSEHOLDS. THEY'RE NOT
NECESSARILY FOCUSED ON BECOMING
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS.
AND, AS MUCH AS WE CAN GIVE THEM
RESOURCES, I THINK IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. AND THE
OTHER ASPECT, WHICH I'VE TRIED
REALLY HARD TO DO IS THE
EDUCATION ON THE DANGERS OF
SOCIAL MEDIA. I DON'T THINK WE
SEE SOMETIMES WHAT'S HAPPENING.
AND YOU SAID A KEY WORD, WHICH I
HEAR CONSTANTLY AS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT EDUCATION. IT'S THE
BYSTANDER EFFECT, A LOT OF THE
TIMES WE SEE IT, WE RECOGNIZE
IT, BUT WE DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO
WITH IT. AND I'M SORRY TO BRING
THIS UP, BUT I DO AS WE JUST,
YOU KNOW, HAD THE ASSASSINATION
OF FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP, WHEN
THEY WERE REFERRING TO THE, THE
YOUNG MAN THAT ACTUALLY
COMMITTED THE ACT, YOU HEARD
FROM ALL HIS CLASSMATES AND OVER
AND OVER THAT THE TWO WORDS THAT
I KEEP HEARING IS, SOCIALLY
AWKWARD, ISOLATED, AND THE OTHER
PORTION WAS BULLYING. HE WAS
EXTREMELY JUST BEING BULLIED
EVERY SINGLE DAY. AND THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT IT. SO THEY KNEW
ABOUT IT. BUT YET EVERYONE FELT
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT. IT WAS
VERY CLEAR THIS YOUNG MAN WAS IN
DISTRESS AND NO ONE REALLY
NECESSARILY. I'M MAKING AN
ASSUMPTION HERE, BUT I'M GOING
TO GUESS THEY DIDN'T REPORT IT
TO, YOU KNOW, THEIR PRINCIPAL,
THEIR PARENTS, THEIR TEACHERS,
AND THEY JUST SAW IT ON THE
PLAYGROUND. I'M SORRY, DURING
LUNCH AND AFTER HOURS WHERE HE
WAS BEING BULLIED AND JUST, FROM
WHAT THEY SAID, THEIR OWN WORDS,
IT WAS VERY EXTREME. AND SO HE
BECAME A RECLUSE AND DIDN'T WANT
TO HANG OUT WITH ANYONE. AND SO
THAT'S, YOU KNOW, WHERE
SOMETIMES SOCIAL MEDIA COULD BE
DANGEROUS, RIGHT? IT WAS IN THE
CASE IN THIS YOUNG MAN. BUT THEN
THEY TURN TO SOCIAL MEDIA FOR
FRIENDS AND SORT OF GUIDANCE.
AND THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY THE
PLACE YOU GO FOR MENTORSHIP. AND
SO THANK YOU, FOR THAT
INFORMATION. SO, WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE OVER TO, THE NEXT PANELIST
AND I WANT TO INTRODUCE, KIM
GRIFFIN ESPERIAN. SHE HAS OVER
25 YEARS EXPERIENCE DEVELOPING
AND IMPLEMENTING A WIDE RANGE OF
SCHOOL MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS,
CURRENTLY SERVING AS THE PROJECT
DIRECTOR. FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND
SCHOOL COUNSELING FOR THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. MISS GRIFFIN
EXPERIENCE WORKS CLOSELY WITH
DISTRICT LEADERS AND SCHOOL
STAFF TO ENHANCE THE
MULTI-TIERED SCHOOL MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORTS AVAILABLE TO
STUDENTS THROUGHOUT LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. WELCOME AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR RUBIO AND MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON SCHOOL
CLIMATE AND STUDENT SAFETY.
THANK YOU, AS MENTIONED, MY NAME
IS KIM GRIFFIN ESPERON, AND I AM
THE PROJECT DIRECTOR THREE OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION'S MENTAL HEALTH AND
SCHOOL COUNSELING UNIT. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU TODAY ABOUT ADDRESSING
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH. AS YOU
HAVE JUST HEARD FROM THE
PREVIOUS PRESENTERS, OUR
STUDENTS HAVE BEEN FACING MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES AT GREATER
RATES IN THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS.
THERE ARE MANY FACTORS
CONTRIBUTING TO THE MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES STUDENTS ARE
FACING TODAY, INCLUDING. BUT NOT
LIMITED TO, ISOLATION AND
LONELINESS, NEGATIVE MESSAGING
AND OR EXPERIENCES OF
DISCRIMINATION, PARTICULARLY
AROUND GENDER IDENTITY AND
ORIENTATION, RACE AND ETHNICITY,
AND IMMIGRATION STATUS.
UNREALISTIC SOCIAL STANDARDS
AROUND PHYSICAL APPEARANCE,
BULLYING AND CYBER BULLYING.
CHRONIC STRESSORS INCLUDING
HOUSING OR FOOD INSECURITY AND
TRAUMA. GRIEF AND LOSS.
FORTUNATELY THERE ARE MANY
PROTECTIVE FACTORS THAT LOWER
THE LIKELIHOOD OF NEGATIVE
OUTCOMES FOR YOUTH. PROTECTIVE
FACTORS THAT PROMOTE RESILIENCE
INCLUDE PARTICIPATION AND GROUP
ACTIVITIES IN SCHOOL AND IN THE
COMMUNITY, SUPPORTIVE FAMILY
RELATIONSHIPS, SOCIAL SUPPORT
INCLUDING A CONNECTION WITH A
CARING, RELIABLE ADULT PHYSICAL
EXERCISE AND HEALTHY DIET.
POSITIVE EMOTIONS AND HOPE FOR
THE FUTURE. ABILITY TO REGULATE
EMOTIONS, PROBLEM SOLVING AND
COMMUNICATION SKILLS, AND ACTIVE
COPING SKILLS. SCHOOLS ARE IN A
UNIQUE POSITION TO MITIGATE RISK
FACTORS AND PROMOTE PROTECTIVE
FACTORS THROUGH A MULTI-TIERED
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT FRAMEWORK. AS
MENTIONED BY DOCTOR TOPALIAN,
TRADITIONALLY, SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITIES HAVE UNDERSTOOD
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES TO BE NECESSARY ONLY
FOR THOSE STUDENTS WHO HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS HAVING A MENTAL
HEALTH DISORDER OR THEY HAVE
ASSUMED THAT ALL STUDENTS
EXPERIENCING MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES REQUIRE INTENSIVE
MENTAL HEALTH INTERVENTIONS.
FORTUNATELY, OUR UNDERSTANDING
HAS EVOLVED TO REFOCUS OUR
ATTENTION ON PREVENTION AND
EARLIER IDENTIFICATION OF
STUDENTS WHO ARE STRUGGLING, AS
WELL AS REFERRAL TO THE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF SERVICES TO
MEET STUDENT NEEDS. ONE OF THE
MOST CRITICAL STRATEGIES IS TO
ENSURE THAT EACH DISTRICT AND
SCHOOL HAS ADOPTED AND FULLY
IMPLEMENTED A COMPREHENSIVE SET
OF POLICIES WITH STEP BY STEP
PROTOCOLS, WHICH ADDRESS STUDENT
EMOTIONAL AND PHYSICAL SAFETY.
THIS INCLUDES PROTOCOLS RELATED
TO BULLYING PREVENTION AND
INTERVENTION, SUICIDE PREVENTION,
INTERVENTION AND POSTVENTION
THREAT ASSESSMENT AND RESPONSE,
AND CRISIS RESPONSE. ENSURING
THAT SCHOOL AND DISTRICT STAFF
ARE WELL TRAINED AND ARE
IMPLEMENTING THESE PROTOCOLS,
PROMOTE STUDENT SAFETY AND WORKS
TO MITIGATE THE EFFECTS OF
EVENTS THAT CAN LEAD TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OR WORSENING OF
MENTAL HEALTH SYMPTOMS. IN
ADDITION, PROMOTING MENTAL
HEALTH LITERACY FOR ALL STAFF,
STUDENTS, AND CAREGIVERS IS AN
ESSENTIAL STRATEGY IN ADVANCING
WELL-BEING AND REDUCING STIGMA
RELATED TO EXPERIENCING MENTAL
HEALTH SYMPTOMS AND DISORDERS.
BY PROVIDING MENTAL HEALTH
LITERACY EDUCATION TO BOTH THE
ADULTS AND THE STUDENTS, THE
EARLY IDENTIFICATION, SUPPORT
AND LINKAGE TO SERVICES OF
STUDENTS IN NEED IS MORE LIKELY.
MENTAL HEALTH LITERACY IS
EFFECTIVE AS MOST EFFECTIVE AND
HAS A WIDER REACH WHEN PROVIDED
THROUGH A VARIETY OF PATHWAYS,
INCLUDING CLASSROOM BASED
CURRICULA, SCHOOL WIDE
CAMPAIGNS, STAFF PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT, AND PARENT
EDUCATION. WORK WORKSHOPS AND
WEB BASED RESOURCES. PEER TO
PEER MENTAL HEALTH OUTREACH AND
ENGAGEMENT IS ALSO INCREASINGLY
VIEWED AS AN EFFECTIVE METHOD OF
REDUCING STIGMA AROUND MENTAL
ILLNESS AND SERVICES,
ENCOURAGING STUDENTS HELP
SEEKING BEHAVIORS, AND PROMOTING
AND REINFORCING THE DEVELOPMENT
OF HEALTHY COPING STRATEGIES.
THERE ARE SEVERAL MODELS OF PEER
TO PEER SUPPORT AVAILABLE FOR
SCHOOLS TO ADOPT. IT IS HIGHLY
RECOMMENDED THAT THE STUDENTS BE
INCLUDED IN THE EXPLORATION AND
ADOPTION OF A MODEL TO ENSURE
BUY IN AND CULTURAL RELEVANCE.
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL LEARNING AND
RESILIENCE. SKILL BUILDING
PROGRAMING HAS ALSO SHOWN TO BE
EFFECTIVE IN INCREASING
RESILIENCE, MENTAL HEALTH AND
WELL-BEING IN STUDENTS WHILE
REDUCING DEPRESSIVE SYMPTOMS,
INTERNALIZING BEHAVIORS AND
ANXIETY WHEN IMPLEMENTED ON A
UNIVERSAL LEVEL. SEL PROGRAMING,
WHICH IS REINFORCED AND THREADED
THROUGHOUT SCHOOL ACTIVITIES,
PROVIDES FOR INCREASED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SKILL
REHEARSAL AND IMPROVED SCHOOL
CLIMATE FOR STUDENTS NEEDING
MORE SUPPORT TO MASTER SEL
SKILLS, ADDITIONAL INSTRUCTION
AND PRACTICING OF SKILLS CAN BE
PROVIDED IN SMALL GROUP SETTINGS,
ENHANCING CONNECTEDNESS BETWEEN
STUDENTS, STAFF AND PARENTS IS
ANOTHER STRATEGY THAT CAN REDUCE
FEELINGS OF ISOLATION AND
LONELINESS. INCREASE POSITIVE
SOCIAL INTERACTION BETWEEN
STUDENTS AND IMPROVE SCHOOL
CLIMATE. THERE ARE MANY WAYS
SCHOOL CAN ENHANCE
CONNECTEDNESS, INCLUDING
INCREASING POSITIVE TWO WAY
COMMUNICATION AND COLLABORATION
BETWEEN STAFF AND PARENTS.
PROVIDING STAFF PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AROUND POSITIVE
DISCIPLINE AND POSITIVE
COMMUNICATION. PROVIDING SEVERAL
AVENUES FOR STUDENT INVOLVEMENT
IN SCHOOL ACTIVITIES, INCLUDING
STUDENT CLUBS, AFFINITY GROUPS,
VOLUNTEER ACTIVITIES, PEER
AMBASSADOR PROGRAMS, AND ACCESS
TO SUPPORT GROUPS. ENCOURAGING
STUDENT VOICE AND DECISION
MAKING AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
DEVELOPING WELL SPACES WHERE
STUDENTS CAN SEEK OUT SUPPORT
AND CONNECTION WITH STAFF OR
OTHER STUDENTS IN A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT, AND IMPLEMENTING
RESTORATIVE PRACTICES SUCH AS
COMMUNITY BUILDING AND
INSTRUCTIONAL CIRCLES. STAFF AND
STUDENT MEDIATION AND HEALING
CIRCLES. AS PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED, SCHOOL STAFF ARE THE
BACKBONE OF ANY SCHOOL SYSTEM,
SIMILAR TO OTHER HELPING
PROFESSIONALS, HOWEVER,
EDUCATORS CAN EXPERIENCE BURNOUT
AND SECONDARY TRAUMATIC STRESS.
THIS REDUCES THEIR OVERALL
WELL-BEING AND EFFECTIVENESS IN
THE CLASSROOM AND AT SCHOOL,
PROVIDING OPPORTUNITIES AND
RESOURCES FOR EDUCATORS TO
PARTICIPATE IN A RANGE OF
WELLNESS PROGRAMS. SUPPORTS THE
WELL-BEING OF BOTH THE STAFF AND
THEIR STUDENTS. SCHOOL STAFF.
SORRY. IN ADDITION, ONE MORE
SYSTEM THAT HELPS SCHOOLS OR
SCHOOLS THAT CAN SERVE AS HUBS
FOR SERVICES AND RESOURCES FOR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES, THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY SCHOOL
FRAMEWORK IS ONE MODEL THAT HAS
BEEN SHOWN TO BE VERY EFFECTIVE
IN PROVIDING THESE SERVICES,
WHICH REDUCES STUDENT AND FAMILY
STRESS AND THEREFORE THEIR
WELL-BEING. OKAY WHEN SELECTING
STRATEGIES, WE ENCOURAGE SCHOOLS
TO USE DATA. WE WANT SCHOOLS TO
LOOK AT SCHOOL CLIMATE DATA,
SUCH AS THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHY
KIDS SURVEY AND THE CALIFORNIA
DASHBOARD. WE ALSO WANT THEM TO
LOOK AT THE INFORMATION THEIR
SCHOOLS COLLECT, SUCH AS
DISCIPLINE, ATTENDANCE, REFERRAL
AND SERVICE DATA TO SEE WHERE
THE GAPS ARE AND TO LOOK AT
DISAGGREGATED DATA SO WE CAN SEE
WHICH STUDENTS ARE BEING SERVED
BEST AND WHICH STUDENTS ARE
STRUGGLING THE MOST. WE ALSO
ENCOURAGE STUDENTS TO USE
QUANTITATIVE DATA. THIS IS
SURVEYS, INTERVIEWS, FOCUS
GROUPS WITH STUDENTS, FAMILY AND
STAFF SO THEY CAN DETERMINE ROOT
CAUSES OF THE DATA POINTS THAT
THEY ARE LOOKING AT, AND TO GET
INPUT AND FEEDBACK ON THE
SERVICES AND PROGRAMING THAT THE
SCHOOLS SELECT IN ORDER TO
INTERVENE. IN ADDITION, I WOULD
ENCOURAGE SCHOOLS TO CONSIDER
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES AND
PROMISING PRACTICES THAT ARE
ADAPTABLE TO THE CULTURAL
BACKGROUND AND COMMUNITIES IN
WHICH THEIR SCHOOLS ARE IN. IN
CLOSING, I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
ADD THAT THERE ARE SO MANY
STRATEGIES OUT THERE THAT
SCHOOLS CAN UTILIZE TO SUPPORT
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH. THE
CAREFUL, SELECTION OF
INTERVENTIONS, HOWEVER, IS KEY.
WHAT WE WANT TO AVOID IS THE
RANDOM ACTS OF SERVICE WHICH
AREN'T TARGETING THE ACTUAL
NEEDS OF EACH SCHOOL. AT THE LA
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION, WE
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE,
COUNSELING, AND I'M SORRY,
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE,
CONSULTATION AND TRAINING FOR
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES AND
THEIR STAFF. THIS IS ALSO
AVAILABLE THROUGH OTHER COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION. SO WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE SCHOOLS AND
DISTRICTS TO UTILIZE THESE
RESOURCES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU, AND YOU KNOW, I KNOW
AS I LOOK OUT IN THE AUDIENCE,
WE HAVE A LOT OF SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS, A LOT OF TEACHERS THAT
I HAPPEN TO KNOW PERSONALLY. SO
I'M GLAD THAT WE HAVE THIS
INFORMATION COMING OUT, THAT WAS
GREAT. AS USUAL, BEING A
TEACHER, I LIKE TO RECAP TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE TAKE AWAY THE MOST,
I WOULD SAY, YOU KNOW, AT LEAST
FROM ME, HIGH LEVEL THINGS THAT
WE CAN DO. AND YOU'VE
HIGHLIGHTED A LOT OF EFFECTIVE
WAYS THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS CAN
HELP, NUMBER ONE, WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE FOCUSING ON
BULLYING PREVENTION AND
INTERVENTION, WHICH IS KEY
SUICIDE PREVENTION AND
INTERVENTION, SCHOOL WIDE
CAMPAIGN TO TACKLE ISSUES IN A
BROAD WAY. PEER TO PEER. PEER TO
PEER SUPPORT HAS PROVEN TO BE
EFFECTIVE AS IT MINIMIZES THE
STIGMA ON ON STUDENTS. AND I
WOULD YOU KNOW, I THINK IT WILL
TRANSCEND TO FAMILIES AS WELL,
INCLUDE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
DEVELOPED BY STUDENTS. SO
THERE'S BUY IN AND IT'S
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE. ALSO
PROVIDE WELL SPACES ON CAMPUSES.
SO THERE'S, STUDENTS IN
DISTRESS. THEY CAN GO SEEK THE
HELP. AND LASTLY, I HEARD YOU
SAY THIS PRETTY FORCEFULLY AVOID
RANDOM ACTS OF SERVICE. SO WITH
THAT, THANK YOU FOR SUCH GREAT
INFORMATION. AND I THINK SOME OF
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS CAN ALREADY
TAKE SOME OF THESE ITEMS AND SEE
IF THEY CAN HELP THEM AND
IMPLEMENT THEM IN THEIR OWN
SCHOOLS. SO NOW I WANT TO TURN
OVER TO, DOCTOR LORETTA WHITSON.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF SCHOOL
COUNSELORS. DOCTOR WILSON IS THE
FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL COUNSELORS, LEADING THE
LARGEST STATE ASSOCIATION FOR
SCHOOL COUNSELORS IN THE NATION
FOR OVER TWO DECADES. WELCOME
AND WHEN YOU'RE READY, YOU HAVE
THE FLOOR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. HAPPY TO BE HERE. AND
I JUST WANT TO SAY HOW MUCH I
APPRECIATE SENATOR RUBIO FOR YOU
CONVENING TODAY'S MEETING. IT'S
SUCH A VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC
TODAY. AND I WOULD BE REMISS IF
I DIDN'T THANK THE OTHER MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR ALL THE
LEGISLATION THAT THEY'VE
AUTHORED AND PASSED OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS REGARDING MENTAL
HEALTH. IT'S BEEN QUITE AMAZING.
AND I THINK WE'RE AT A I'M GOING
TO KIND OF SHIFT A LITTLE BIT.
I'M GOING TO TALK ABOUT THINGS
THAT I THINK THAT ARE REALLY
HAPPENING IN REGARDS TO POLICY
AND THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL TO IMPLEMENT THE
POLICIES. ALSO THAT HAVE
HAPPENED OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS. SO I'M I'M JUST HAPPY TO
SHARE SOME THINGS. AND I'M LIKE
YOU SAID, I'VE BEEN DOING THIS A
LONG TIME. A COUPLE OF DECADES,
WHAT I LEARNED PROBABLY THE MOST
WAS WHEN I WAS A SCHOOL DISTRICT
ADMINISTRATOR IN THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AREA. SO THAT WAS FOR 22
YEARS, WHERE I WAS WORKING, TO
MAKE TRY TO MAKE THINGS HAPPEN.
WE ARE A LOCAL CONTROLLED STATE,
AND SO AT THE LOCAL LEVEL IS SO
VERY IMPORTANT HOW WE ARE ABLE
TO HELP SCHOOL DISTRICTS, TO
IMPLEMENT THE NEEDS AND
RECOGNIZE THE NEEDS OF MENTAL
HEALTH IN OUR, WITH OUR STUDENTS,
SO HERE ARE SOME DATA PIECES,
THAT WE HAVE OVER 13,000 SCHOOL
COUNSELORS WORKING IN CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS BY FAR THE LARGEST
STATE. 15% OF SCHOOL COUNSELORS
WORK IN CALIFORNIA. AND, THERE'S
33 UNIVERSITIES PROGRAMS. SO THE
ABILITY FOR US TO SCALE UP HAS
BEEN THERE, THE OTHER PIECE IS
THAT WE HAVE AND I KNOW THAT,
THAT IT WAS SHARED THAT WE HAD
660, YOU KNOW, WELL, LAST THAT
WAS TWO YEARS AGO. I WAS ABLE TO
PULL DOWN SOME DATA AND WE'RE
ACTUALLY AT 443 STUDENTS PER
SCHOOL COUNSELOR. AND I'LL SHOW
YOU WHY. THAT'S IMPORTANT. SO
THERE'S OTHER DATA SETS THAT ARE
HAPPENING, BUT ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I WAS SHARED WITH ME, I
DON'T HAVE THE DATA IN FRONT OF
ME, BUT IT WAS SHARED BY,
SOMEONE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION THAT WE
ONLY HAVE LOST 250 EMPLOYEES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THIS YEAR. AND WHY
THAT'S SIGNIFICANT IS THAT IN
TIMES OF FINANCIAL CRISES WITH,
WHEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE TO
ADJUST THEIR EMPLOYEES AND LET
PEOPLE GO, IT'S LIKE TEACHERS
GET A COLD, WE LOSE A FEW, BUT
THE SUPPORT SERVICES IS LIKE WE
GET PNEUMONIA, YOU KNOW, IT'S
LIKE WE JUST LOSE PEOPLE. AND WE
DIDN'T THIS YEAR. AND SO, YOU
KNOW, WE CAN ASSUME WHY THAT
MIGHT BE, YOU KNOW, MAYBE THAT
WE ARE NOW BECOMING MORE
INTEGRATED WITHIN THE SYSTEMS.
AND THEY SEE OUR VALUE IN A
DIFFERENT WAY. AND I ALSO THINK
IT'S THE DEFINING OF WHAT A
SCHOOL DOES, YOU KNOW, AND GOING
BEYOND THE IDEA THAT WE'RE JUST
PRODUCING STUDENTS THROUGH AN
ACADEMIC PROCESS IN ORDER TO
GRADUATE AND TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
BUT IT'S ALSO LOOKING AT THE
WHOLE CHILD AS JANINE HAS SAYS,
IS THAT THE WHOLE CHILD IS SO
IMPORTANT. AND THAT SHIFT IN
PERSPECTIVE, I THINK, IS REALLY
CONTRIBUTING TO SOME OF THE
CHANGES THAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO.
ALSO, THE FACT IS THAT WE'VE HAD
QUITE A BIT OF CRISES WITH OUR
STUDENTS, AND SO THAT IS ALSO
FORCED IT. BUT I'VE ALSO SEE
THAT THAT'S BEEN HAPPENING OVER
THE COURSE OF TIME. THERE WAS A
REPORT THAT WAS OUT, IN 2017, I
BELIEVE, 2018, THAT SAID THAT WE
HAVE A WORKFORCE, SHORTAGE IN
REGARDS TO MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE
STAFF. AND SO THAT WAS OUT OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO STATE
UNIVERSITY THAT RESEARCH. AND WE
ARE SEEING THAT NOW. WE'RE
SEEING THE ISSUES. SO I WANTED
TO POINT OUT HOW MANY PROGRAMS
WE HAVE FOR SCHOOL COUNSELORS,
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
SIGNIFICANT. WHEN YOU HAVE OTHER
PROGRAMS OR OTHER PROFESSIONS
THAT MIGHT HAVE 6 OR 8 TRAINING
PROGRAMS, WE HAVE QUITE A BIT,
MEANING WE'RE PRODUCING ABOUT
2000 SCHOOL COUNSELORS A YEAR,
WHICH ALSO COULD BE WHY WE ARE
ALSO SEEING OUR RATIOS DROP IN
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WORKING IN
OUR SCHOOLS CREATE. SO, SO
YOU'LL SEE HERE IN THIS DATA
SET, WE, THE STUDENT TO SCHOOL
COUNSELOR RATIO IN CALIFORNIA IN
2012, 2013 WAS 826 STUDENTS.
ONE. NOW WE'RE HALF THAT AMOUNT
APPROXIMATELY. AND SO WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT IT, AND FOR, SENATOR
RUBIO, WHO WAS A TEACHER, WHEN
YOU HAVE A COUPLE EXTRA KIDS IN
YOUR CLASSROOM, IT CHANGES
THINGS, YOU KNOW, SO WHEN YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE FROM 800 TO 400,
IT'S I THINK 800 WOULD BE MORE
LIKE URGENT CARE. WE'RE
RESPONDING TO CRISIS AND WE
SPEND A LOT OF OUR TIME WHEN YOU
HAVE LESS, WHEN YOU'RE GOING,
YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU HAVE 400,
THEN YOU ARE ABLE TO DO
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGIC WORK,
AND SO THAT'S, WE'RE NOT WHERE
WE WANT TO BE, WHICH IS THE
RECOMMENDATION FOR AT THE
NATIONAL LEVELS TO 150 STUDENTS
FOR EVERY SCHOOL COUNSELOR. BUT
WE'RE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. AND SO I APPLAUD
THAT, THAT WE ARE AND I EQUATE
THAT TO SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
LOCALLY, SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
MAKING THOSE CHOICES. AND I
THINK THAT'S BEEN VERY POSITIVE
IN THAT WAY. WE'VE ALSO BEEN
BRINGING IN QUITE A BIT OF
ELEMENTARY COUNSELORS. BEFORE
THAT WAS UNHEARD OF TO HAVE AN
ELEMENTARY COUNSELOR, BUT NOW
WE'RE SEEING, FROM DISTRICT TO
DISTRICT THAT THEY'RE BRINGING
IN ELEMENTARY COUNSELORS, WHICH
ARE MIDDLE SCHOOL COUNSELORS.
AND OUR HIGH SCHOOL COUNSELORS
SAY, OH MY GOSH, YOU'RE SO MUCH
BETTER FOR THEM BECAUSE THEY'RE
TEACHING THEM HOW SOCIAL SKILLS,
COPING SKILLS. ALSO, LOOKING AT
IT FROM A WHOLE SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENT AND SAFETY AND
INCLUSION, AS WAS SAID IN
REGARDS TO THE, ATTEMPTED
ASSASSINATION ON TRUMP. YOU
KNOW, THIS IS A KID THAT WAS IN
ISOLATION AND WHAT WAS DONE OR
NOT DONE IN REGARDS TO TRYING TO
BRING HIM FORWARD AND HAVE HIM
BEING INCLUDED. AND I THINK
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT IN THE
WORK THAT'S BEING DONE BY ALL
THE SCHOOL BASED MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS ON CAMPUS SOCIAL
WORKERS, PSYCHOLOGISTS AND
SCHOOL COUNSELORS. SO IF YOU'LL
SEE THIS HERE, THERE'S THESE ARE
THE THINGS THAT HAVE HAPPENED
MOST RECENTLY IN REGARDS TO THE,
THAT HAS AFFECTED THE SCHOOL
COUNSELING PROFESSION, BUT ALSO
IS AFFECTED, IN GENERAL, WHAT
WE'RE DOING IN SCHOOLS, THE
FIRST ONE IS THAT THERE WAS A
GOLDEN STATE TEACHER GRANT THAT
WAS, THAT WOULD GIVE ABOUT
$20,000 FOR TEACHERS GOING IN
THE PROFESSION BECAUSE WE HAD A
WE HAVE A TEACHER SHORTAGE, AND
WE'VE HAD A TEACHER SHORTAGE,
BUT IT WAS ALSO A FEW YEARS AGO,
WE'VE INCLUDED SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGISTS, SCHOOL SOCIAL
WORKERS, AND SCHOOL COUNSELORS
IN THAT WHERE THEY'RE ABLE TO
DRAW DOWN FUNDS. SO THAT IS ALSO
INCREASING OUR ENROLLMENT AND
OUR UNIVERSITY PROGRAMS, WHICH
IS EXCELLENT, ALSO IN 2022, WE
HAD $184 MILLION THAT WAS
APPLIED FOR A RESIDENCY PROGRAM.
SO WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT IT'S
AN INDUCTION PROGRAM. SO YOU CAN
TRAIN FOLKS IN GRADUATE SCHOOL.
AND TO BE SCHOOL COUNSELORS. BUT
THAT INDUCTION, WHEN YOU
ACTUALLY TRANSITION INTO THE
JOB, WE SAID WE HAD KIND OF HAD
TO GO WITH GOD PHILOSOPHY. YOU
KNOW, YOU'RE YOU'RE ON YOUR OWN.
BUT NOW WE ARE ACTUALLY USING
THIS RESIDENCY PROGRAM TO REALLY
IMPLEMENT EFFECTIVE COUNSELING
BY WORKING WITH THEM FOR TWO
YEARS. WITHIN THAT, THEIR FIRST
TWO YEARS OF THE PROGRAM AND
HELPING THEM BE STRONGER AND,
PARTNERING WITH THEM. AND I'M
PARTNERING WITH A LOT OF
DISTRICTS AND HELPING THEM IN
THAT PROCESS. THERE'S ANOTHER
PROGRAM THAT IS JUST NOW COMING
FORWARD THAT WILL REQUIRE
SUPERVISION FROM SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGISTS, SOCIAL WORKERS
AND COUNSELORS. BUT IT ALSO
ADDRESSES WHAT WAS SAID BY MR.
WICKS IN REGARDS TO WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. SO WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT NOW WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE THESE WELLNESS COACHES
COMING IN OUR CAMPUSES. THAT
WILL BE SUPERVISING THEIR TWO
YEAR AND FOUR YEAR TRAINED
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE ARE
DESIGNATED TO REALLY BE THERE TO
HELP DRAW OUT KIDS AND TO WORK
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE WITH THE,
HIGHLY EDUCATED, MENTAL HEALTH
STAFF TO DO THAT WORK. AND WE'RE
EXCITED ABOUT THAT, AND ALSO A
LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT HOW
THAT'S GOING TO TRANSITION IN
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT IS
HAPPENING NOW AND THEN JUST
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE WE'RE
DEALING WITH OUR WITHIN OUR
SCOPE OF PRACTICES EFFECTIVELY.
AND WHERE THERE'S A SUPERVISION
PIECE THAT IS ADEQUATE, WE ALSO
HAVE, WE HAD A BILL THAT WAS
PASSED, IN IN 2022, WHICH WAS
THE AB 2058, WHICH KIRK SILVA,
SPONSORED. AND THAT WAS TO
REALLY UP OUR EDUCATIONAL CODES
HAVING TO DO WITH EDUCATIONAL
COUNSELING AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES WITHIN OUR SCHOOLS. WE
HAD NOT REALLY CHANGED THAT LAW
FOR ABOUT 35 YEARS. SO THAT'S
BEEN UPDATED. OUT OF THAT, WE
WERE ABLE TO GET MEDI-CAL
BILLING FOR SCHOOL COUNSELORS,
EQUITABLE TO EVERYONE ELSE,
MEANING LICENSED PROFESSIONAL
COUNSELORS, MARRIAGE AND FAMILY
COUNSELORS, PSYCHOLOGISTS,
SOCIAL WORKERS, WE ARE THE FIRST
IN THE NATION TO HAVE THAT
PROVISION NOW SO THAT WE'RE ABLE
TO BILL, THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
WILL BILL AND GET MONEY BACK SO
THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO SUSTAIN, A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE ON THEIR
WORKFORCE. AND THAT'S WHAT WE
WANT BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO
LOSE SCHOOL COUNSELORS OR OTHERS
IN THE PROCESS, THERE'S ANOTHER
PIECE WITH THAT MEDI-CAL BILLING
PIECE IS THAT WE HAVE A,
MULTI-PAYER FEE SCHEDULE THAT IS
COMING FORWARD, AND THAT IS
ABOUT HOW WE CAN USE PRIVATE
INSURANCE TO BE ABLE TO OFFSET
THE COSTS FOR MENTAL AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND PHYSICAL
HEALTH. TYPES OF TREATMENT ON
SCHOOL CAMPUSES. THERE WAS A
COHORT, ONE THAT HAPPENED
STARTING JANUARY. COHORT TWO
STARTED JULY 1ST. AND SO WE'RE
SEEING HOW THAT'S GOING TO WORK.
SO IT'S A COMPLEX SYSTEM. I WAS
ON A COMMITTEE WITH THE STATE,
FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS TRYING TO
WORK ON HOW THIS WOULD HAPPEN.
AND SO WE WILL SEE HOW THAT GOES
FORWARD. BUT THAT IS ANOTHER,
THING COMING OUT OF CALIFORNIA'S
ADMINISTRATION. AND GOVERNOR
GAVIN, GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND THE
IDEAS IS HOW DO WE DEAL WITH
SOME OF THE OBSTACLES, WHICH IS
FUNDING. SO, FUNDING WAS AN
OBSTACLE THEN WE WOULDN'T BE
TALKING ABOUT THIS, BUT IT IS.
AND SO HOW CAN WE BRING IN MONEY
TO SUSTAIN SOME OF THE WORK THAT
WE THINK IS SO VERY IMPORTANT
WITH THAT? SO SINCE THAT TIME,
WE, WE CREATED STANDARDS AND
THOSE ARE BASED ON EMPIRICAL
RESEARCH AND BEST PRACTICES AND
THOSE STANDARDS ARE WITHIN SIX
AREAS OF IMPORTANCE. ONE OF THE
NEWEST ADDITIONS TO THIS, THIS
IS A IT WAS REVISED FROM 22,007.
SO IT WAS A LONG TIME BEFORE WE
HAD REVISED THESE. BUT ONE OF
THE BIGGEST THINGS IS THAT WE
HAVE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES NOW
AS A STANDALONE STANDARD, AND
THAT IS REALLY TELLING A STORY
ABOUT HOW WE WORK WITHIN THE
AREAS THAT ALL OF YOU HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT, WHICH IS QUITE
WONDERFUL. AND, I'M GOING TO
SHOW YOU THE MENTAL HEALTH ONE
HERE JUST TO SHOW YOU HOW THIS
WORKS, BECAUSE AS WE TALKED
ABOUT MULTI-TIERED SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT, THIS IS HOW THIS WORKS
WHEN YOU THINK OF MENTAL HEALTH.
SO IF YOU LOOK AT A TIERED ONE
SUPPORT, WHICH IS SCHOOL
CLIMATE, WHICH IS WHERE WE WOULD
CUT, WOULD HAVE CAUGHT THIS
CHILD AND, AND PROBABLY
PERFORMED, TIER TWO AND TIER
THREE SUPPORT FOR HIM. BUT HOW
DO YOU FIND AND FIND KIDS? HOW
DO YOU MAKE SURE THAT SCHOOL IS
SAFE AND THAT KIDS FEEL ENGAGED
AND CONNECTED TO EVERYONE? AND
THEN WHAT DO YOU DO WHEN THEY'RE
NOT? AND, SO WAY WE WORK IS THAT
WE COLLABORATE WITH ALL
EDUCATIONAL PROFESSIONALS. WE
WORK WITH THE TEACHERS AND
STRENGTHEN THE TEACHERS
CAPACITY. OTHER STAFF MEMBERS
CAPACITY. WE ALSO, DO VARIOUS
MENTAL HEALTH ASSESSMENTS. HOW
DO YOU FIND OUT IF YOU NEED
THEM? THERE'S UNIVERSAL
SCREENINGS AND OTHER WAYS THAT
WE DETERMINE. WE ALSO HAVE WAYS
FOR TEACHERS TO BE ABLE TO
REPORT OUT AND ALSO TRAIN OTHER
STUDENTS, BECAUSE YOU KNOW HOW
IT IS WHEN YOU'RE ESPECIALLY
LET'S GO WITH HIGH SCHOOL ALL OF
US HAVE HAD THAT EXPERIENCE,
RIGHT. SO WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
YOU'RE A HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT?
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO SNITCH ON
SOMEONE YOU KNOW? I REMEMBER A
TIME THAT SOMEONE TOLD ME THAT
THEY WERE SUICIDAL AND I DIDN'T
DO ANYTHING ABOUT THAT, YOU
KNOW, I DIDN'T KNOW. AND HE
COMMITTED SUICIDE. I DIDN'T KNOW
THAT. AND PROBABLY WAS THE THING
THAT HAPPENED IN MY PAST THAT
DROVE ME INTO THIS PROFESSION
BECAUSE I DIDN'T KNOW THE
REPORT. SO WE WORKED IN THAT
LEVEL TO HELP STUDENTS KNOW IT'S
YOU'RE NOT SNITCHING WHEN YOU'RE
TELLING US, YOU KNOW, WE'RE
WE'RE THERE TO SUPPORT YOU AND
HELP YOU. THE OTHER PIECE THAT
WE DO WITH THIS IS WE HAVE LIKE
INITIAL PIECES LIKE, GROUP
COUNSELING, INDIVIDUAL
COUNSELING, CLASSROOM LESSONS
AND THINGS LIKE THAT TO REALLY
TEACH AND HELP THE, STUDENTS IN
REGARDS TO THAT, ALL OF YOU HAVE
TALKED ABOUT LISTENING TO
STUDENTS. YES, THAT'S PART OF
THAT TOO, IS LISTENING AND BEING
AVAILABLE, BEING OUT THERE AND
BEING PRESENT FOR KIDS SO THAT
THEY FEEL CONNECTED TO US. AND
THE THIRD ONE IS, IS REALLY
INTENSIVE TREATMENT. IF YOU IF
THIS TRIANGLE WAS UPSIDE DOWN,
THIS MODEL WAS UPSIDE DOWN, WE'D
BE SPENDING. SO MUCH MONEY ON
THE 3% OR 4% THAT REALLY NEEDED
INTENSIVE WORK WHERE WE WANT TO
SPEND MOST OF OUR TIME IS IN, IS
IN THE, PREVENTION AREA BECAUSE
IT'S COST EFFECTIVE AND IT WORKS,
ONE OF THE WAYS WE DO THAT IS WE
WORK WITHIN THE, WE ACTUALLY, I
WAS JUST I JUST CAME BACK FROM A
TRIP TO THE MIDWEST WHERE WE HAD
OUR NATIONAL CONVENTION, AND
CALIFORNIA WON THE PINNACLE
AWARD, WHICH IS THE ONLY AWARD
EVERY YEAR GIVEN TO A STATE FOR
DOING EXCEPTIONAL WORK IN A
CERTAIN AREA WITHIN THE SCHOOL
COUNSELING PROFESSION. WHAT WE
WON THE AWARD FOR WAS FOR OUR
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH WEEK,
WHICH WE DO EVERY YEAR, WHICH
AND WE HAVE LESSONS, WE HAVE
TRAININGS, WE HAVE MARQUEE SIGNS
AND SOCIAL MEDIA POSTS ON
REDUCING STIGMA. AND IN AND
HONORING KIDS WITHIN THE IDEA OF
THEIR OWN MENTAL WELL-BEING. AND
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT, AND IT'S
ACTUALLY EXTREMELY EXCITING TO
SEE THIS AS A FIVE YEAR. WE'VE
BEEN DOING IT JUST HOW IT'S
GROWN FROM DISTRICT TO DISTRICT,
AND HOW THERE ARE, RECOGNIZING
KIDS IN THAT AREA. SO LET'S SEE,
WE HAVE THIS, LET ME THERE WE GO.
SO AND THIS IS THE ACUTE AND
CHRONIC MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
AND SO 1970, WE, A BILL WAS
PASSED AND IT WAS BEFORE MY
TIME. I JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW
I'M NOT THAT OLD, BUT IT WAS IT
HAD TO DO WITH INTEGRATED
SERVICES AND THE BEST I COULD.
I'M KIND OF NERDY WITH LOOKING
UP STUFF LIKE THIS AND SEEING
WHEN LAWS PASSED AND KIND OF
INTERESTED IN IT, BUT IT PASSED
AND IT TALKED ABOUT INTEGRATION
OF SERVICES AND THE WORK THAT WE
DO, LIKE MR. WICKS DOES WITH OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS. AND SO THAT
WAS THE FIRST INDICATORS THAT,
OUR PUPIL PERSONNEL SERVICES,
OUR MENTAL HEALTH STAFF WORK
WITH OUTSIDE FOLKS TO REALLY
BRIDGE THE GAPS THAT WE HAVE
WITH STUDENTS. AND SO, THAT ALSO
TALKED ABOUT WHEN PEOPLE COME ON
SCHOOL CAMPUSES THAT THEY HAVE
TO BE SUPERVISED BY, SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGISTS, SOCIAL WORKERS
AND COUNSELORS. SO WE THINK
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
EVERYONE'S TALKING TO EACH
OTHER. WE'RE ALL ALL WORKING
TOGETHER, AND WE'RE ABLE TO
SHARE, EVEN IF WE'RE HIPAA OR
WE'RE FERPA, WHICH IS THE
REGULATIONS ON HOW WE SHARE
INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE BRIDGED
THOSE GAPS AND WE'VE DONE THAT
NOT ONLY JUST WITH THAT STATUTE,
BUT WITH STATUTES THAT WERE JUST
RECENTLY PASSED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN TALK TO EACH OTHER
IN THAT AREA, MOVING ON. I THINK
I DON'T KNOW WHERE TO POINT.
OKAY. HERE. SO WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT THIS, I THINK WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT HOW DO WE SCALE UP
WITH THAT. WE ALSO NEED TO THINK
ABOUT THE 60% OF OUR, SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT ARE SMALL. SO HOW
DO YOU DO MENTAL HEALTH WHEN YOU
HAVE A SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT HAS
300 KIDS IN THEIR IT'S
DIFFICULT, YOU KNOW, HOW DO YOU
HAVE ENOUGH STAFFING TO DO THAT?
HOW DO YOU WORK IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH COMMUNITY AGENCIES? HOW DO
YOU BRING IN ENOUGH PEOPLE AND
HOW DOES EVERYONE FIT WITHIN
THEIR ROLE OF, YOU KNOW, TO
BUILD THEIR CONFIDENCE IN THE IN
THE SYSTEMS THAT THEY WORK
WITHIN, BUT ALSO IN THEIR SCOPE
OF SERVICES AND WORKING TOGETHER
COLLABORATIVELY. AND I THINK
THAT'S WHERE, I'M HOPING THAT AS
WE MOVE FORWARD, AS THE STATE
HAS TAKEN A LEAD AND IS
RECOGNIZED FOR THEIR WORK IN
THIS AREA AND ALL THE NEW THINGS
THAT THEY'VE HAD THAT WE ALSO
LOOK AT HOW WE HELP LOCALLY TO
DO WITH ALL DISTRICTS, NOT JUST
THE BIGGER DISTRICTS, BUT THE
SMALLER DISTRICTS AND, AND HELP
MEET THOSE NEEDS AND WORK
TOGETHER. SO THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE THE TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, AND AGAIN, EVERYBODY
HERE IS, SHARING A LOT OF
IMPORTANT INFORMATION. AND TO
ME, IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT,
YOU KNOW, I SHARE WITH YOU HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS THAT YOU'RE
BRINGING RESIDENCY PROGRAMS,
WHICH IS A TWO YEAR PROGRAM. I
REMEMBER, BEING ASSISTANT
PRINCIPAL IN LOSING TEACHERS
THAT HAD SPENT A LIFETIME TRYING
TO GET THEIR CREDENTIALS AND GET
THE WORK IN. THEY WOULD WORK FOR
SIX MONTHS AND THEN REALIZE IT
WASN'T FOR THEM BECAUSE THEY
JUST COULDN'T HANDLE IT. AND SO
I THINK HANDS ON AND MAYBE, A
LITTLE BIT MORE SPECIFICALLY,
HAVING MENTORS AS THEY GO
THROUGH THOSE PROGRAMS IS KEY TO
SUCCESS. BUT I ALSO WANT TO SAY,
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT I ALSO
THINK IS IMPORTANT, YOU KNOW,
TRANSITIONING FROM, JUST SEEING
THE CHILD AS PROGRESSION FROM
ONE GRADE TO THE NEXT IS GETTING
THEM OUT OF THE SYSTEM AND
GIVING THEM A DIPLOMA TO
TRANSITION INTO NOW, SEEING THEM
AS HUMAN BEINGS, A WHOLE CHILD,
AND MAKING SURE THAT ALL THEIR
NEEDS ARE MET, NOT JUST
EDUCATIONAL NEEDS, BUT ALSO
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH AND THEIR
WELL-BEING, BUT LASTLY, MONEY
CONTINUES TO ALWAYS BE AN ISSUE
AS IT PERTAINS TO PROGRAMS AND
SCHOOLS AND OUTSIDE OF SCHOOLS.
AND THIS, EVEN THOUGH IT'S A
COMPLICATED TIER SYSTEM, BUT NOW
YOU'RE ABLE TO LEVERAGE MEDI-CAL
AND PRIVATE INSURANCE DOLLARS.
SO THAT THAT'S WONDERFUL, SO
LASTLY, BUT NOT LEAST, WE HAVE,
SOMEONE HERE THAT'S GOING TO
SHARE A LITTLE BIT OF, LET ME
SEE IF I CAN FIND MY. THERE WE
GO, A LITTLE BIT MORE. AND ONCE
AGAIN, I'LL REMIND OUR AUDIENCE
THAT YOU HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ASK QUESTIONS. ONCE WE'RE DONE,
I WANT TO INTRODUCE JOEL
SISNEROS, ADMINISTRATOR OF
STUDENT HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES FOR LA USD. AND MR.
SISNEROS, WHEN YOU'RE READY, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. WELL, THANK YOU
SO MUCH, SENATOR RUBIO, FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. AND CERTAINLY, I
THINK IN THE 20 YEARS THAT I'VE
BEEN DOING THIS WORK, I'VE NEVER
FELT SO WELCOMED IN PUBLIC
SPACES AND THAT THE NARRATIVE
AND THE POLICY IS REALLY
BEGINNING TO SUPPORT THE WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING, SO, SO THANK
YOU FOR BEING A CHAMPION. AND
SACRAMENTO AND FOR EVERYONE ELSE
THAT'S DOING THAT, NOT ONLY IN
SACRAMENTO, BUT IN COMMUNITIES
ACROSS OUR WONDERFUL STATE, AS
MENTIONED, JOEL CISNEROS WITH
LAUSD AND I, AS YOU WERE
MENTIONING, YOU KNOW, SMALL
DISTRICTS, I FELT A LITTLE BIT
LIKE I NEEDED TO, YOU KNOW, FEEL
SMALL BECAUSE CERTAINLY LAUSD IS
OUR LARGEST DISTRICT IN
CALIFORNIA, IT'S THE SECOND
LARGEST DISTRICT IN THE US. WE
HAVE CLOSE TO HALF A MILLION
STUDENTS ACROSS 700MI². SO THAT
IN ITSELF CAN PRESENT SOME
CHALLENGES. CERTAINLY. AND I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
HAVE DONE AS, LA UNIFIED, VERY
STRATEGICALLY IS A COUPLE YEARS
AGO WHEN OUR SUPERINTENDENT,
ALBERTO CARVALHO, CAME ON BOARD,
IS CREATED A VERY, COHERENT AND
STRATEGIC PLAN THAT REALLY LAID
OUT THE WHAT WE NEEDED TO DO, TO
REALLY PROMOTE ACADEMIC
EXCELLENCE, AND FOR THE FIRST
TIME SINCE I'VE BEEN IN THIS
DISTRICT, A WHOLE PILLAR
DEDICATED AROUND JOY AND
WELLNESS AND PROMOTING SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL HEALTH. SO ONE OF THE
MY REMARKS ARE GOING TO BE
REALLY ROOTED AROUND THOSE. THE
JOINT WELLNESS AREA AND THE
BENEFITS OF GOING LAST. I'M ALSO
THE CLOSER. SO I ALSO THINK THAT
IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY. I'M GOING
TO KEEP MY REMARKS SHORT BECAUSE
I WANT TO ENGAGE IN THE DIALOG
AS SENATOR RUBIO SAID,
OFTENTIMES THAT'S WHERE WHERE
THE MAGIC HAPPENS. SO, FOR US
WITH REALLY TALKING ABOUT THIS
AREA AROUND JOY AND WELLNESS AND
PROMOTING MENTAL HEALTH ACROSS
LA UNIFIED, I'M REALLY GOING TO
FOCUS ON THREE AREAS, REALLY
AROUND STIGMA REDUCTION. I KNOW
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
ALREADY MENTIONED THAT, ALSO
AROUND ACCESS, WHEN WE WHAT DOES
ACCESS LOOK LIKE TO MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES? AND THEN
LASTLY, AGAIN, WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE DOING. SO I'LL
BE ABLE TO SHARE SOME EXAMPLES
OF HOW WE'RE LEVERAGING, NOT
ONLY PARTNERING WITH, COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS, BUT ALSO
PARTNERING WITH THE STATE,
PARTNERING WITH THE FEDS TO GET
SOME FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO PILOT
SOME OF THESE PROJECTS. SO IN
THE AREA OF STIGMA REDUCTION, WE
KNOW THAT THAT'S ALWAYS A
CHALLENGE WITH THE DISTRICT THAT,
AS LARGE AS OURS, WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN SUPPORT IN
EVERY WAY POSSIBLE. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'VE BEEN REALLY
FOCUSING IN ON IS REALLY WORKING
ALONGSIDE PARENTS AND
CAREGIVERS, STUDENTS AND STAFF
TO START DEVELOPING AND
CO-CREATING SOLUTIONS. RIGHT.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT IN MY
PREVIOUS ROLES, I WAS THE
DIRECTOR OF MENTAL HEALTH, ONE
OF THE FIRST THINGS I MENTIONED
TO MY STAFF, YOU NEED TO GET
OVER YOUR TITLE AND GO INTO THE
INTO THE COMMUNITY AND ASK FOR
ANSWERS AND SEEK ANSWERS, RIGHT
TOO OFTEN, AS INDIVIDUALS WITH A
BUNCH OF LETTERS AFTER OUR
NAMES, WE WALK INTO COMMUNITIES
WITH THE SPACE OF PRIVILEGE AND
WITH THE MINDSET THAT WE CAN FIX
THINGS. AND SO WE REALLY NEED TO
SHIFT THAT PARADIGM. AND IT
REALLY STARTS TO ADDRESS THE
STIGMA REDUCTION. SO WHAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO DO IS REALLY FOCUS
ON PARENT EMPOWERMENT AND WE'VE
DEVELOPED PARENT ACADEMIES THAT
HAVE BEEN EXTREMELY SUCCESSFUL,
IN DELIVERING SOME OF THAT WORK
FOR OUR PARENTS AND CAREGIVERS.
111, WORKSHOP THAT WE'VE
DEVELOPED A FEW YEARS AGO WAS
REALLY A PROMISING PRACTICE,
RECOGNIZING THAT NOT ALL
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES ARE
ANCHORED AROUND, COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR OR DIVERSE COMMUNITIES. SO
IT WAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO DEVELOP
WHAT WE CALLED A WORKSHOP,
RESILIENT FAMILIES. AND IT WAS
REALLY, AGAIN, DEVELOPED IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH COMMUNITY, THE
COMMUNITY THAT WE SERVED,
SECONDLY, WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
PEER PEER TO PEER PEER
EMPOWERMENT, ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS IS WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
LAUNCH A PEER, MENTAL HEALTH
YOUTH SYMPOSIUM, WE JUST DID OUR
SECOND ROUND OF IT BACK IN LATE
APRIL, RIGHT BEFORE TO KICK OFF,
MENTAL HEALTH AWARENESS MONTH.
AND WE HAD CLOSE TO 500 STUDENTS
SHOW UP ON A SATURDAY ON A
SATURDAY TO REALLY TALK ABOUT
MENTAL HEALTH AND WHAT THEY'RE
DOING IN THEIR COMMUNITIES TO
PROMOTE THAT, AND IT'S A
FANTASTIC OPPORTUNITY THAT I
REALLY WELCOME, DISTRICTS OUT IN
CALIFORNIA TO BE ABLE TO FIGURE
HOW TO EITHER WORK TOGETHER WITH
OTHER DISTRICTS TO, YOU KNOW, DO
SUCH THINGS. LASTLY, WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT STAFF, I KNOW IT'S
BEEN MENTIONED ALREADY, BUT ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE BEEN
LAUNCHING AND THIS IS OUR SECOND
YEAR, IS LOOKING AT HOW DO WE
BUILD THE CAPACITIES OF STAFF,
BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE JUST DON'T GIVE ANOTHER
MANDATE, LIKE IT'S BEEN
MENTIONED. BUT THAT WE LIKE WE
CALL THIS TRIPLE TRACK, LEARNING
SO THAT NOT ONLY WE BUILD THE
CAPACITIES OF STAFF, THE PARENTS
AND THE STUDENTS. SO, IN
SEPTEMBER, WE DO A WHOLE, ROUND
ALL SCHOOLS, ALL STAFF, PARENTS
AND CAREGIVERS AND STUDENTS WILL
BE GOING THROUGH, A PRESENTATION
AND WORKSHOPS AROUND SUICIDE
PREVENTION AND AWARENESS, TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE MONTH, MOVING
ALONG, I WAS TALKING ABOUT
ACCESS EARLIER AS WELL. SO ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO DO IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH, WITH LACO, WITH KIM AND
OTHER COLLEAGUES AT THE COUNTY
IS REALLY BEING ABLE TO EXPAND
OUR TELE MENTAL HEALTH, PROJECT.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT ACCESS, I KNOW MAYBE TEN
YEARS AGO, A LOT OF OUR MENTAL
HEALTH COLLEAGUES WOULD HAVE
BEEN, LIKE, SCOFFED AT THE IDEA
OF TELEHEALTH. BUT REALLY, I
THINK THE PANDEMIC HAS REALLY
KIND OF FORCED US AND KIND OF TO
SEE THE BENEFITS OF EMBRACING
TECHNOLOGY AS AN AVENUE TO
REALLY PROMOTE MENTAL HEALTH AND
ACCESS. ONE OF THE OTHER
PROJECTS THAT I REALLY AM VERY
PROUD OF IS THAT WE DO HAVE OUR
OWN PSYCHIATRIC EMERGENCY
RESPONSE TEAM THAT PROVIDES
SUPPORT TO STUDENTS THAT ARE IN
A CRISIS, EITHER TO BECAUSE THEY
MIGHT HARM THEMSELVES OR OTHERS,
NOT OBVIOUSLY. I'M SAYING THAT
THAT AS A DISTRICT AS BIG AS
OURS, WE HAVE THE PRIVILEGE TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT, AND WE'VE
INVESTED IN THOSE RESOURCES. BUT
IT'S AGAIN, THINKING OUTSIDE OF
THE BOX. IT'S WHAT MY
RECOMMENDATION AS FAR AS
DISTRICTS, MAYBE DISTRICTS COULD
COME TOGETHER, MAYBE THEY CAN
WORK WITH THE COUNTY OFFICE OF
ED TO COME UP WITH IDEAS AND
SOLUTIONS TO REALLY DEVELOP HOME
GROWN IDEAS THAT ARE GOING TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF THE STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES. BECAUSE WHAT WE
FOUND WAS THAT WE HAVE STAFF
THAT HAVE BEEN TRAINED TO WORK
WITH CHILDREN AND ASSESS
CHILDREN IN PSYCHIATRIC
EMERGENCIES, AND OFTENTIMES WHEN
WE RELY ON OTHER COUNTY
ENTITIES, THEY MAY HAVE THE
TRAINING, BUT THEY ALSO, YOU
KNOW, THEY'RE THEY'RE SUPPORTING
THE ENTIRE COUNTY. RIGHT? SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT, YOU
KNOW, WHEN WE GREW THIS PROGRAM,
IT REALLY ALLOWED US TO SOLVE
SOLUTIONS OR CREATE SOLUTIONS
FOR SOME PROBLEMS THAT WE WERE
EXPERIENCING. LASTLY, AND
QUICKLY HERE, WE TALKED ABOUT
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND KIND
OF THE SOME OF THE CHALLENGES,
AGAIN, REALLY ENCOURAGING
DISTRICTS TO REALLY BE ABLE TO
LOOK AT WHAT ARE THE STATE
FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES AS A
DISTRICT, WE WERE FORTUNATE TO
ALSO JUST RECEIVE THE WELLNESS
COACH GRANT, AND SO WE'RE REALLY
LOOKING AT, WHAT I LIKE TO SAY,
DIVERSIFY THE MENTAL HEALTH OR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TEAM. I THINK
THAT'S REALLY WHAT IT COMES DOWN
TO, THAT I THINK EVERYONE HAS A
ROLE. THERE'S A DIVERSE SET, NOT
ONLY RACIAL AND ETHNIC, BUT ALSO
FROM A LIVED EXPERIENCE OR,
PROFESSIONALISM. RIGHT. SO
MEANING, LIKE, WE COULD HAVE
PEERS, WE COULD HAVE PARENTS, WE
COULD HAVE, YOU KNOW, THE
PSYCHIATRIST, THE THERAPIST. BUT
WE REALLY NEED A DIVERSE, THAT
TEAM NEEDS TO BE DIVERSE. AND SO
WE'RE REALLY LEVERAGING SOME
STATE DOLLARS THAT WERE JUST
AWARDED TO US TO REALLY DO THAT
WORK, SO WITH THAT, I'LL THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY, AND
I'LL HAND IT BACK TO YOU. THANK
YOU, YEAH, I REALLY APPRECIATE
ALL OF YOU COMING HERE. AND I
YOU KNOW, I HAVE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS OF MY OWN, BUT I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR AUDIENCE
HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO ASK
QUESTIONS. BUT AS I HAVE DONE
FOR ALL THE OTHER SPEAKERS,
THINGS THAT STAND OUT FOR ME IS,
YOU KNOW, WHAT YOU SAID, WHICH
IS REALLY INTERESTING AND
CRITICAL AND IT'S VERY SPECIFIC
WAY REDUCING THE MINDSET OF
WE'RE HERE TO FIX THINGS. AND
INSTEAD EMPOWERING THOSE, THAT
ARE AROUND US TO, TO HELP
THEMSELVES AND, PARENT
EMPOWERMENT, WHICH IS KEY IN, IN
OUR COMMUNITIES, AND I THINK
THAT CREATING, PROGRAMS WHERE
THEY'RE INCLUDED, AS THE WORD
WAS USED EARLIER, THERE'S BUY IN
FROM OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND
PARENTS THAT WANT TO MAKE IT
BETTER, I ALSO KNOW THAT, WHEN I
TALK ABOUT TELEHEALTH, WHICH IS
IMPORTANT, YOU'RE SAYING THAT
YOU'RE FINDING SUCCESS. WE
DIDN'T USE THIS PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC, AND LATELY I'VE BEEN
TALKING TO SOME TEACHERS. AND,
YOU KNOW, I CONTINUE TO HEAR
THINGS LIKE, PARENTS DON'T SHOW
UP TO PARENT TEACHER CONFERENCES
AND I WANT TO OFFER TO THOSE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND EVERYONE
THAT HEARS ME IS THAT WE SHOULD
BE OFFERING PARENT TEACHER
CONFERENCE ONLINE THROUGH ZOOM,
BECAUSE THEN WE WOULD HAVE 100%
PARTICIPATION, MANY PARENTS
DON'T ATTEND, NOT BECAUSE THEY
DON'T CARE ABOUT THEIR CHILDREN,
BUT BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO GO TO
WORK AND THEY DON'T HAVE
CHILDCARE. AND THE ISSUES ARE
MASSIVE, BUT WE OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO A PARENT
TEACHER CONFERENCE ONLINE. I CAN
ASSURE YOU WE WOULD ALMOST HAVE
100% PARTICIPATION. SO, YOU
KNOW, NOT ONLY IN YOUR FIELD,
BUT I'VE HEARD IT THROUGHOUT IN
MANY FIELDS THAT JUST ACCESS ON
ZOOM AND NOT BEING ABLE TO
ATTEND PERSONALLY ALWAYS YIELDS
A BIGGER SUCCESSES. SO THANK YOU
FOR ALL THE INFORMATION. AND
AGAIN I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR AUDIENCE HAS TIME TO COME UP
AND ASK QUESTIONS. SO I HOPE
THEY WERE WRITING THEIR
QUESTIONS DOWN, I ALSO WANT TO
AGAIN THANK MY COLLEAGUES WHO
WERE UP AND DOWN THE STATE WHO
BELONG TO THE SELECT COMMITTEE,
AND THEY'RE WATCHING ONLINE AND
ALL THOSE THAT COULDN'T MAKE IT
AGAIN ACROSS THE STATE, THIS
LINK WILL BE ON OUR WEBSITE SO
THEY CAN VIEW IT OR GET THE
INFORMATION AND CONTACTS IF THEY
NEED IT. BUT I'M GOING TO INVITE
OUR AUDIENCE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME. IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS,
YOU CAN LINE UP BEHIND THE
PODIUM AND ASK YOUR QUESTION ON
THE MICROPHONE, AND WE'LL DO OUR
VERY BEST TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS. ANYONE THANK YOU,
MISS WOLF. HI EVERYONE. AND WE
ALL HAVE APPROXIMATELY ONE
MINUTE PER SPEAKER TO ASK THE
QUESTION. THANK YOU.
WHILE THEY'RE FIGURING OUT THE
MICROPHONE, IT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY HAVE TO BE A
QUESTION. IF ANYONE JUST WANTS
TO MAKE A COMMENT, INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES AND LET US KNOW. YOU
KNOW, ANYTHING THAT YOU WANT TO
OFFER, PLEASE FEEL FREE.
ONLINE. THEY WON'T HEAR HER.
YEAH, WE'RE JUST GOING TO ADJUST
A LITTLE. WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
THE YOUNG LADIES MOVE TO THE
SIDE AND WE'LL JUST USE THE
FIRST MICROPHONE, IF THAT'S
OKAY. THANK YOU FOR BEING
FLEXIBLE. OKAY SOUNDS LIKE IT.
YEAH HI, EVERYONE. MY NAME IS
CINDY WILL. I'M A BOARD MEMBER
WITH MOUNTAIN VIEW SCHOOL
DISTRICT HERE IN EL MONTE AND
SOUTH EL MONTE, I FIRST OF ALL,
YOU KNOW, I REALLY APPRECIATE,
THE SENATOR FOR INVITING ME HERE
PERSONALLY. AND, ALSO BE A PART
OF THIS CONVERSATION. AND THIS
IS A CONVERSATION I'M VERY
PASSIONATE ABOUT, AS I WAS
PREVIOUSLY A DOCTOR STUDENT FOR
PSYCHOLOGY. AND SO I WAS A
MEMBER OF AMERICAN PSYCHOLOGY
ASSOCIATION, AND MOUNTAIN VIEW
SCHOOL DISTRICT IS ACTUALLY A
LEADER IN COMMUNITY SCHOOLS. WE
RECENTLY RECEIVED EIGHT GRANTS
FOR COMMUNITY SCHOOL FOR ALL OF
OUR EIGHTH, EIGHT SCHOOLS, WHICH
IS QUITE AMAZING, MY QUESTION IS
THAT, YOU KNOW, JUST, YOU KNOW,
WHEN I'M LISTENING TO SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT YOU SHARED, IT
TOUCHES ME BECAUSE, AND I'M
WONDERING, ASKING ALL THE
PANELISTS IF THERE'S ANY
CONVERSATION AROUND CONSCIOUS OR
UNCONSCIOUS TRAINING FROM BOTH,
FROM A STAFF PERSPECTIVE, THE
REASON WHY IS BECAUSE I'M ALSO
THE FOUNDER OF ANTI-ASIAN HATE
CRIMES COALITION, AND NOT TOO
LONG AGO, I HAD A PARENT IN
NORTHERN LOS ANGELES COUNTY,
ANOTHER DISTRICT REACHED OUT TO
ME. HER CHILD WAS BULLIED FOR
ABOUT A YEAR AND A HALF RACIAL
SLURS BEING READ, SAID LOUDLY
THROUGHOUT THE SCHOOL FOR A
YEAR, AND A HALF, WHAT ENDED UP
OCCURRING IS THAT, THIS CHILD,
NINE YEAR OLD CHILD, WAS BEATEN
UP, WAS ARM CHOKED, ENDED UP IN
THE HOSPITAL BY TEN KIDS. THE
MOTHER ALSO SUFFERED TREMENDOUS
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES, BECAUSE
SHE THOUGHT HER SON WAS GOING TO
DIE AND THEY COULDN'T SLEEP FOR
WEEKS. AND MONTHS. SHE DIDN'T
EAT, SHE DIDN'T DRINK. SHE WOULD
JUST SPEND 30S. SORRY. SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, SO JUST WONDERING
IF YOU HAVE, YOU KNOW, IF THERE
ARE ANY CONVERSATION THAT YOU
HEARD ABOUT REGARDS TO CONSCIOUS
AND UNCONSCIOUS BIAS TRAINING.
AND I JUST WANT TO END WITH
THIS, IT WAS ALSO RACIAL SLURS
WAS ALSO SAID. AND ALSO WAS
BULLIED BY, THE ADMINISTRATORS
ON THAT CAMPUS SITE. ANYONE WANT
TO TAKE THAT QUESTION, I CAN
ADDRESS THAT. SO THE YWCA, OUR
MISSION STATEMENT IS TO
ELIMINATE RACISM AND EMPOWER
WOMEN, SO THAT'S A LOT OF THE
WORK I DO NOW FOR THE AGENCY IS
DEVELOPING OUR RACIAL AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE PROGRAMING. SO I WORK
REALLY CLOSELY WITH OUR YOUTH
SPECIALISTS. AND SO THAT TRAUMA
PREVENTION PROGRAM I MENTIONED,
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO, YOU KNOW,
INTERFACE WITH THE YOUTH AND
REALLY TALK ABOUT ANTI-BULLYING
AND REALLY RACIAL AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE. AND SO BRINGING A LOT
OF THOSE INTERNAL COMPONENTS WE
WORK ON WITH OUR STAFF TO THAT
MORE AGE APPROPRIATE YOUTH
DISCUSSION, SO IT'S DEFINITELY
SOMETHING THAT I KNOW WE HAVE
BEEN TRYING TO DO MORE OF AND
JUST LOOKING FOR DIFFERENT WAYS
TO GET IT OUT INTO THE
COMMUNITY, THAT'S SOME OF THE
WORK WE DID WITH LACO AND THEIR
FAMILY, THEY HAVE A FAMILY
RESOURCE PROGRAM FOR THOSE THAT
HAVE YOUTH THAT ARE SYSTEM
INVOLVED. AND SO THAT WAS A
PRESENTATION WAS ABOUT RACIAL
AND SOCIAL JUSTICE AND ADVOCACY
AND REALLY LOOKING AT THAT. SO,
I KNOW WE HAVE SOME RESOURCES TO
OFFER IF YOU WANTED TO CONNECT.
AND WE CAN TALK ABOUT THAT.
THANK YOU. AND, CINDY, WE'LL
MAKE SURE YOU GET THAT
INFORMATION. THANK YOU, NEXT
GUEST. YOU HAVE ONE MINUTE FOR
YOUR COMMENTS. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. CAN YOU HEAR ME? YES.
THERE. OKAY. HI. MY NAME IS
LIZETTE MENDEZ GARCIA. I'M A
BOARD MEMBER FOR THE HARMONY
CITY SCHOOL DISTRICT, BUT I'M
ALSO A SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST. AND
FOR THE LAST THREE YEARS, A
SPECIAL EDUCATION PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATOR. SO MY COMMENT IS
RECOMMENDATION IS COMING. AS A
PUBLIC SCHOOL EMPLOYEE, I JUST
CAME FROM THE CALIFORNIA MTSS
CONFERENCE IN ANAHEIM. I WAS
JUST THERE YESTERDAY. IT'S TIME.
RIGHT? THERE'S SO MANY
RECOMMENDATIONS REGARDING
TRAINING THAT OUR STAFF NEED.
PLANNING TIME. TIME TO LOOK AT
DATA. THERE'S NOT ENOUGH TIME
AND I'M JUST GOING TO GIVE YOU
AN EXAMPLE WHERE I WORK, WE
HAVE, 106 186 WORK DAYS, 180
STUDENT SCHOOL DAYS. RIGHT. ONLY
TWO OF THOSE ARE DEDICATED PD
DAYS. THE OTHER FOUR ARE TEACHER
PREP DAYS. RIGHT. AND THEY'RE
USING THAT TIME TO LESSON PLAN
TO DO GRADING. SO THERE'S A HUGE
BARRIER OF JUST FINDING THE TIME
TO MEET WITH TEACHERS. DEPENDING
ON YOUR DISTRICT, DIFFERENT
DISTRICTS HAVE DIFFERENT,
CONTRACTS. REGARDING THE TIMES
THAT YOU CAN MEET WITH TEACHERS,
WHEN YOU CAN HOLD MEETINGS WITH
PARENTS, SOMETIMES YOU'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO HAVE A MEETING BEFORE
SCHOOL OR AFTER SCHOOL. IT HAS
TO BE DURING TEACHER CONTRACT
TIME. SO THAT CAN BE A BARRIER.
SO THAT'S JUST SOMETHING I'M A
RECOMMENDATION I HAVE IS
COLLECTING DATA TO REALLY SEE
ACROSS CALIFORNIA THE AMOUNT OF
TIME, ON AVERAGE, THAT TEACHERS
HAVE FOR PD FOR, HOW MANY TIMES
A SCHOOL TEAM IS ABLE TO MEET TO
DISCUSS MTSS THERE'S NOT EVEN
TIME TO EVEN SIT DOWN TO TALK
ABOUT YOUR MTSS FRAMEWORK,
BECAUSE ONCE SCHOOL STARTS,
YOU'RE RIDING THE BUS, YOU'RE
BUILDING IT, AND THERE'S A FLAT
TIRE ALREADY, SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANYONE WANT TO JUST
MAKE A COMMENT? I CAN, I, I WAS
IN MONROVIA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AS AN ADMINISTRATOR,
AND IT TOOK ME ABOUT TEN YEARS
TO GET THE BARGAINING UNIT TO
CHANGE AND TO LOOK AT THOSE
KINDS OF RESTRICTIONS. SO I KNOW
THAT EXISTS. AND IN SOME
DISTRICTS, WE'RE MOVING FORWARD,
I THINK, IN A POSITIVE WAY, BY
HAVING MORE TIME. BUT THERE'S A
LOT OF DISTRICTS THAT STILL SEE
THAT PD TIME PLANNING TIME, ALL
THOSE THINGS OUTSIDE OF THE YOU
KNOW, AND HAVING THAT WITHIN THE
CONTRACT SHOULD BE INCLUDED. AND
I JUST APPLAUD YOU FOR BRINGING
THAT FORWARD BECAUSE IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE LOOK AT THAT
TOO. IN REGARDS TO STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH. THANK YOU. AND
THANK YOU FOR THAT COMMENT. AND
I KNOW FOR US, I MEAN, IT'S
MAYBE AN IDEA WE NEED TO
EXPLORE. DO WE, YOU KNOW, HAVE A
BILL POLICY ON MAKING MORE HOURS
AVAILABLE. AND I KNOW WE DON'T
LIKE MANDATES. I'M, YOU KNOW, A
TEACHER AS WELL. ADMINISTRATOR
AT ONE POINT, BUT I THINK IT'S
NECESSARY. WE REALLY WANT TO
CHANGE THE CONVERSATION AND
REALLY TACKLE THE ISSUE THAT IS,
REALLY PLAGUING OUR KIDS. WE DO
NEED THE TIME. I RECOGNIZE THAT
BECAUSE AS A TEACHER, YOU'RE
GOING TO YOU'RE STRUGGLING JUST
TO DO LESSON PLANNING AND REPORT
CARDS THAT WE DON'T THINK OF THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL IMPACT ON KIDS. SO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THAT UP
AND I'LL KEEP IT FOR A BILL NEXT
YEAR. THANK YOU. AND YOU WANTED
TO MAKE A COMMENT AS WELL? I, I
WAS GOING TO SAY SAME THINGS.
YOU WERE JUST THAT IT'S A I I'M
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD. AND IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
AGAIN JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVEN IF WE DO HAVE THE TIME IS
PROVIDED, THE CASELOADS ARE SO
HIGH THAT IT HAS TO BE TO THAT
RATIO. I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT YOU NEED TO LIKE. YOU KNOW,
JUST OVERALL LIKE LIKE
LEGISLATORS NEED TO BE AWARE OF
AS WELL BECAUSE THE TIME IS
LIMITED, EVEN WITH THE HIGH
CASELOADS. THANK YOU. NEXT
GUEST. HI. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS DOCTOR SABRINA BO. I'M A
TRUSTEE FOR THE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. I'M ALSO A PUBLIC
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATOR,
ADMINISTRATOR, AND A PARENT OF
AN ELEMENTARY STUDENT RECEIVING
COUNSELING SERVICES. SO FIRST I
WANT TO SHARE SOME
APPRECIATIONS, AND THEN I HAVE A
QUESTION ABOUT DATA, I REALLY
APPRECIATE, MR. HICKS, YOUR
SHOUT OUT TO AZUSA WITH THE WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING IN OUR
COMMUNITY, WITH FAMILIES IN
SCHOOLS AND SORT OF THE
INTERGENERATIONAL APPROACH. I
CAN SEE THE IMPACT THAT THE
COMMUNITY SCHOOL MODELS AND
COMMUNITY CIRCLES ARE HAVING
WITH MY CHILD'S, WITH MY OWN
CHILD, AND HOW SHE'S ABLE TO
PROBLEM SOLVE, AND BUILD
RESILIENCY SO I CAN SEE IT AS A
PARENT. AND I'M I'M SO GRATEFUL
TO HELP AMPLIFY THAT MESSAGE OF
SUCCESS, FROM MY POSITION AS A
AS A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER, I ALSO
HAVE A QUESTION AROUND, KIND OF
A LARGER SYSTEM OF, ANALYSIS.
RIGHT. AS WE ROLL OUT
INITIATIVES. AND THERE ARE MANY
THINGS TO DO IN MANY POCKETS,
I'M WONDERING IF THERE IS
ALREADY A, AN INITIATIVE TO LOOK
AT FROM A STATE PERSPECTIVE, THE
EFFICACY OF MENTAL HEALTH
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS VIS A VIS
STUDENT, DISCIPLINE SUSPENSION
AND EXPULSION RATES. AND I KNOW
THAT'S JUST ONE VERY THAT'S ONE
SLICE. BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THAT SUSPENSION AND EXPULSION
RATE IS SOMETHING THAT'S ON OUR
DASHBOARD. AND SO AS A AS AN
ADMINISTRATOR AND ALSO AS A
TRUSTEE, I WONDER IF THERE'S
SOMETHING ALREADY IN THE WORKS
TO LOOK AT THAT, SPECIFICALLY.
WELL, I'LL SHARE A LITTLE BIT OF
WHAT I DO KNOW. IT'S A TOPIC
THAT COMES UP VERY OFTEN, AND I
KNOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA
RUBIO PASSED A BILL A FEW YEARS
BACK WHERE, KIDS WERE BEING
SUSPENDED AT THE AGE OF FIVE AND
SIX FOR BEHAVIOR ISSUES. AND AT
THAT TIME, I MEAN, IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE RECOGNIZE THAT
CHILDREN ARE BEING CHILDREN AND
GROWING UP. IF YOU'RE BEING
SUSPENDED AT SIX, SEVEN, EIGHT,
IT JUST BECOMES, A BIGGER ISSUE
LATER IN LIFE. SO THERE'S BEEN
SEVERAL BILLS THAT THAT HAVE
BEEN ATTEMPTED, AND PEOPLE FEEL
DIFFERENTLY ABOUT DIFFERENT
THINGS, BUT IT'S A TOPIC THAT
COMES UP, THERE'S BEEN SEVERAL
BILLS. I DON'T HAVE THE
INFORMATION HERE, BUT I WILL
CERTAINLY REACH OUT. AND, WITH
THE INFORMATION ON THAT, IF YOU
HAVE ANYTHING TO SHARE, PLEASE
FEEL FREE. I WOULD SAY THAT
ISOLATION HAS NEVER, RESEARCH
WISE HAS EVER WORKED TO CHANGE
BEHAVIOR. SO WHEN YOU SUSPEND A
KID OR EXPEL A KID AND NOT HAVE
A PLACE FOR THEM TO GO OR A IN
A, TRANSITION BACK IN WHICH IS
WE'RE DOING THAT MORE WITH
RESTORATIVE PRACTICES AND THINGS
LIKE THAT TO REALLY HELP THEM
UNDERSTAND AND HAVE THAT AS A
LEARNING MOMENT AND NOT THAT
BEHAVIOR. DEFINE THEM. AND SO
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF WORK ON
THE GROUND LEVEL AS LONG AS WELL
AS LEGISLATIVELY, TO NOT OVERLY
SUSPEND BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, MY
EXPERIENCE HAS TAUGHT ME THAT
ADMINISTRATORS SEE THAT AS THE
DISCIPLINE APPROACH RATHER THAN
A REALLY PREVENTATIVE APPROACH
OR A WAY OF USING IT AS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR A CHILD TO GROW
THROUGH THAT. SO AND COULD I
JUST ADD THAT I KNOW THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IS ALSO LOOKING AT
THAT, AS MORE KIDS ARE BEING
REFERRED FOR NONPUBLIC SCHOOLS
AND RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
CENTERS IN THE PRESCHOOL AGE
GROUP. SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
THEY'RE LOOKING AT TO SEE, THE
DATA AND TO LOOK AT DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT, YOU KNOW, THEY CAN
DO MOVING FORWARD. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT. NEXT
GUEST. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME
IS SHEILA GONZALEZ, AND I
REPRESENT CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER.
WE'RE A STATEWIDE COALITION THAT
CHAMPIONS THE SUCCESS OF ENGLISH
LEARNERS ACROSS THE STATE, AND
JUST WANT TO SAY EXPRESS
APPRECIATION TO SENATOR RUBIO
FOR REALLY TALKING ABOUT THIS
ISSUE, WHEN WE LOOK AT THE MOST
IMPACTED STUDENT GROUPS ACROSS
THE STATE, IMMIGRANT NEWCOMER
STUDENTS OR STUDENTS THAT COME
IN OFTEN, IF THEY'RE ASYLEE
REFUGEES, UNACCOMPANIED MINORS
HAVE MANY, MANY, MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS. AND OFTEN OUR SYSTEMS AND
OUR SCHOOL SYSTEMS ARE NOT
DESIGNED TO SUPPORT THEM, AND SO
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU,
BRINGING UP THIS ISSUE, BUT I
DID WANT TO JUST MAYBE ASK A
QUESTION ABOUT, IN TERMS OF THE
WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE IN YOUR
AREAS, WHERE HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE
TO FOCUS ON IMMIGRANT NEWCOMER
STUDENTS? WHAT HAVE YOU SEEN?
WHAT'S BEEN SUCCESSFUL WITH THEM?
IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO OUR ORGANIZATION.
I'LL JUMP RIGHT IN AND JUST SAY,
YEAH, ONE OF THE BEST THINGS HAS
BEEN THAT TO FIND SOMEONE WHO IS
ABLE TO SPEAK THE SAME LANGUAGE
OR IS CULTURALLY FROM THE SAME,
PLACE LOCATION WHERE THEY WERE
ABLE TO RELATE AND BE CONNECTED
TO THAT STUDENT AND TO BE ABLE
TO WORK WITH THE FAMILY, TO BE
ABLE TO ENGAGE THEM, TO BE ABLE
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH WHATEVER
THEY NEED, BUT ALSO WORKING WITH
THE STAFF AT THE SCHOOL SITE TO
UNDERSTAND THE CULTURE IN ITSELF
OF WHERE THEY'RE COMING FROM,
AND NOT THINKING THAT THE
STUDENT WHO'S SITTING IN FROM
NINTH GRADE COMING AND I'LL
SPEAK FROM MY EXPERIENCE COMING
FROM ARMENIA, WHO DOESN'T SPEAK
ARMENIAN, IS ACTING OUT BECAUSE
HE HAS BEHAVIOR ISSUES OR IS
INTELLECTUALLY DISABLED IN THAT
SENSE, BUT WORKING TOWARD
TOWARDS MORE OF LIKE A
UNDERSTANDING AND FACILITATING.
BUT I THINK, AND WORKING IN
PARENTS, TALKING TO
ADMINISTRATORS AND TO DIFFERENT
OUTLETS IN THE COMMUNITY,
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO FIND
THOSE MENTORS OR THOSE PEOPLE
THAT THEY COULD BE THE CONDUIT
TO HELP THOSE, PARENTS IN THE
STUDENT IN THE SCHOOL SYSTEMS.
WELL, AND I'LL SHARE FOR MY OWN
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE, I THINK
MOST OF YOU KNOW MY STORY. I
HAVE A TWIN BROTHER, WHO, DIDN'T
DO VERY WELL BECAUSE HE WAS A
SPANISH SPEAKER AT THE TIME. HE
WAS DIAGNOSED IN TERMS OF HIS
ACADEMIC, YOU KNOW, ABILITY AND
BECAUSE HE DIDN'T SPEAK THE
LANGUAGE, HE WAS DEEMED BACK IN
THE 70S, YOU KNOW, FORGIVE THE
EXPRESSION, BUT WE ALL KNOW THEY
USED IT MENTALLY. THEY TOOK MY
MOTHER THAT SHE THAT HE WOULD
NEVER LEARN AND REALLY PUT HIM
IN A SPECIAL ED SCHOOL WITH
SEVERELY HANDICAPPED CHILDREN,
AND HE NEVER REALLY SUCCEEDED IN
HIS ACADEMIC TRAJECTORY. HE
DROPPED OUT OF SCHOOL. AND SO WE
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE CULTURALLY
COMPETENT SUPPORT SYSTEM AND
EDUCATION. AND SO I THINK I
HEARD ALL OF YOU UP HERE AT ONE
POINT OR ANOTHER TALK ABOUT JUST
THAT, THAT, CULTURALLY COMPETENT
EDUCATION. BUT ALSO, YOU KNOW,
WHATEVER SUPPORT SYSTEM THAT WE
PROVIDE, IT HAS TO BE VERY
SPECIFIC TO WHO WE'RE SERVICING.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT.
YES. OUR NEXT GUEST. GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU TO ALL THE,
RESPECTIVE EXPERTS IN THEIR
FIELDS THAT ARE HERE TODAY, MY
NAME IS HECTOR DELGADO, AND I'VE
HAD THE HONOR AND PRIVILEGE OF
WORKING WITH THE CITY OF SOUTH
EL MONTE. ALSO, AS AN EDUCATOR,
I'M CURRENTLY THE DROPOUT
PREVENTION DIRECTOR AT ONE OF
OUR LOCAL HIGH SCHOOLS. WORKING
WITH OUR MOST AT PROMISE, YOUTH.
ALSO, MY BACKGROUND HAS BEEN
WORKING WITH HOMELESS AND FOSTER
YOUTH, CHILDREN, INCARCERATED
YOUTH, AND VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. SO THE HOLISTIC
APPROACH THAT YOU GUYS HAVE
TALKED ABOUT, I'VE LIVED IT FOR
THE LAST 25 YEARS, AND I APPLAUD
YOU FOR THE WORK AND THE EFFORT
THAT GOES IN, NOW I'M GOING TO
PLAY A LITTLE BIT OF DEVIL'S
ADVOCATE WITH RESPECT TO OUR
MTSS SYSTEM, OUR ACCESS FOR
SERVICES, OUR HEALING CIRCLES,
OUR DIFFERENT WORKSHOPS WITH ALL
THE DIFFERENT SERVICES. HOW DO
WE IMPLEMENT ACCOUNTABILITY
WITHOUT NECESSARILY GIVING
EVERYONE OR EVERY ONE OF OUR
STUDENTS THAT MIGHT HAVE AN
ISSUE, A MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE OR
CRISIS, A PASS? GREAT QUESTION.
ANYONE WANT TO TAKE THAT? I
WILL. SO ONE OF THE THINGS WE DO
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGISTS IS ALSO
EDUCATING THAT EVERY CHILD DOES.
I MEAN, WHEN WE LOOK AT A CHILD,
WHEN THEY'RE HAVING THESE
ISSUES, IT'S SOMETIMES JUST A
CHILD BEING A CHILD IN ITSELF
AND NOT HAVING IT TO ESCALATE IT
INTO DIFFERENT LEVELS OF BEING
ABLE TO, YOU KNOW, LEARNING
THOSE RESILIENCY SKILLS AND
BEING ABLE TO OVERCOME AND BEING
ABLE TO, BE ABLE TO COPE WITH
LIFE ISSUES IN ITSELF. BUT
HAVING THAT SUPPORT IN THE
BACKGROUND, BUT EMPOWERING THEM
IN THAT SENSE, DOES THAT MAKE
SENSE? LIKE, I MEAN, IT
SHOULDN'T ACTUALLY WE WERE
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION THE
OTHER DAY WITH ONE OF A COUPLE
OF US IN THE CAST, AND THAT'S
WHAT IT IS. EVERY BEHAVIOR DOES
NOT MEAN IT'S AN ISSUE. IT'S A
CHILD WHO NEEDS TO FALL TO BE
ABLE TO GET UP, TO BE ABLE TO
SURVIVE, BECAUSE WE ARE GIVING
THEM ALWAYS THE TOOLS INSTEAD OF
THEM FINDING OUT ABOUT LIFE
EXPERIENCES AND BEING ABLE TO DO
WHAT WE DID AS KIDS BACK IN THE
DAYS IN SOME WAY, RIGHT? THERE'S
LIMITS, BUT ALSO LOOKING FROM
THE BACKGROUND AND EMPOWERING
THEM TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT. AND
I HEAR WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IN
THAT SENSE, THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR QUESTION, NEXT GUEST.
HI. MY NAME IS MARY MORALES. I'M
A TEACHER, PART OF THE
ASSOCIATED POMONA TEACHERS. I'M
THE VICE PRESIDENT, AND I HAVE
TWO QUESTIONS, MY FIRST QUESTION
IS, IF SCHOOLS AND DISTRICTS
TAKE ON THIS TREMENDOUS
RESPONSIBILITY, HOW CAN WE
ENSURE THAT IT WILL BE FULLY
FUNDED AND FULLY STAFFED AND
HAVE OVERSIGHT AND, GUARANTEE
FISCAL RESPONSIBILITY WITH THE
FUNDS? IF NOT, IF WE DON'T HAVE
THOSE THREE THINGS? THE BIGGEST
ISSUE I SEE IS WE'RE PUTTING
LIKE A BAND AID ON A BROKEN ARM.
IT'S WONDERFUL. LIKE, I, I'VE
BEEN A TEACHER 24 YEARS, SO I AM
VERY INVESTED IN WHAT I DO. BUT
WITH MORE AND MORE GOING ON,
MORE RESPONSIBILITY PILED UPON
US. IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT. FOR
US. SO THE SECOND QUESTION IS,
HOW ARE WE GOING TO PAY THE
PROFESSIONALS IN THE MENTAL
HEALTH FIELDS WHO CAN TRULY HELP
OUR STUDENTS WITH THESE NEEDS?
FUNDING IS ALWAYS HUGE IN
REGARDS TO GETTING, YOU KNOW,
GETTING MSW. WE'RE GETTING
THEY'RE BEING PAID BETTER
SOMEWHERE ELSE. SO WE WIND UP
WITH PEOPLE WHO STAY THERE A
YEAR OR TWO YEARS, FIND A BETTER
JOB IN THERE OUT. SO THAT PART
IS ALSO ANOTHER ISSUE I SEE. AND
JUST REALLY QUICKLY WHAT YOU
BROUGHT UP ABOUT SUSPENSIONS. I
AGREE, SUSPENSIONS ARE NOT
ALWAYS THE WAY, BUT MAYBE TAKING
THAT SUSPENSION DAY AND SAYING
HOW DO WE HELP THIS KID? SO
INSTEAD OF CALLING IT A
SUSPENSION, MAYBE A MENTAL
HEALTH DAY OR A MENTAL HEALTH
HOUR WHERE WE'RE PROVIDING
SUPPORT FOR THAT CHILD AT THAT
MOMENT, I HAD MY THUMB BROKEN BY
A FOUR YEAR OLD. SO YOU MAY
LAUGH AND SAY, HOW COULD A FOUR
YEAR OLD HAVE BROKEN YOUR THUMB?
WELL, IT HAPPENS AND HE WAS FOUR
AND HE WAS STRONG. HE TOOK ON A
POLICE OFFICER AT ONE POINT. SO,
YOU KNOW, HE NEEDED SOME TIME TO
FIGURE OUT WHY WAS HE DOING
THIS. AND WE NEED THAT FUNDING.
SO THANK YOU. THOSE ARE MY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION. ANYONE WANTED. WELL, I
THINK THE COUNT, THOSE THE IDEA
OF MEDI-CAL AND, THAT KIND OF
FUNDING IS REALLY IMPORTANT IN
REGARDS TO ANSWERING THE
PROBLEMS IN REGARDS TO FINANCING
OUR SCHOOLS. I THINK IT'S WHEN I
DID THAT PROGRAM AND MY SCHOOL
DISTRICT, WE WERE BRINGING IN A
FEW HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR, AND IT'S A SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICT OF 7000 KIDS. SO THAT
WAS SUBSTANTIAL. IT HIRED A
COUPLE PEOPLE TO HELP WITH THAT,
WITH THE NEEDS. BUT I THINK TOO,
THE ACCOUNTABILITY HAS CHANGED
IN REGARDS TO SINCE WE HAD THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
AND LOCAL CONTROL, PROGRAMS OUT
THERE WHERE WE'RE LOOKING AT
MORE THAN JUST A STANDARDIZED
TEST BEFORE 2012. THAT'S HOW WE
EVALUATED SCHOOLS. NOW WE
EVALUATE THEM ON MULTIPLE
LEVELS. CAN WE DO BETTER? YES,
WE CAN. AND I THINK WE CAN DO
THINGS THAT SOME OTHER STATES
ARE DOING IN REGARDS TO,
MEASURING WHAT WE WANT AND
MAKING SURE WE'RE GETTING WHAT
WE NEED IN REGARDS TO THE
SERVICES FOR KIDS. SO I
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. THANK YOU. AND I'LL
JUST ADD FROM THE STATE, I NEVER
STOP PUSHING. THERE'S SO MANY
EDUCATORS IN OUR IN OUR STATE,
YOU KNOW, MR. PORTANTINO, WHO
YOU ALL KNOW IS A SENATOR
NEIGHBORING DISTRICT, HE'S VERY
COMMITTED. HIM. AND I ALWAYS
EITHER COAUTHOR BILLS TRYING TO
GET, YOU KNOW, MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IN OUR SCHOOLS. AND
IT'S A CHALLENGE. IT WILL
CONTINUE TO BE A LITTLE BIT OF A
CHALLENGE. BUT, YOU KNOW, I WANT
TO JUST BRING US BACK TO WHAT
MR. SISNEROS SAYS. YOU KNOW,
THERE'S A LOT OF GRANT PROGRAMS,
TOO, A LOT OF GRANT FUNDING. AND
I THINK YOU SAID YOU'RE ABLE TO
LEVERAGE SOME GRANTS TO TAKE
CARE OF SOME OF THESE ISSUES,
BUT NOT A SOLUTION. BUT NO, WE
HEAR YOU AND WE UNDERSTAND WE
NEED TO INVEST MORE IN OUR
SCHOOL SYSTEM. SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS. NEXT GUEST. THANK
YOU. HELLO. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS SUE LOW, I REPRESENT
ASSOCIATED POMONA TEACHERS, AND
I'M A SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST, I'VE
BEEN IN EDUCATION FOR 30 YEARS,
AND I MY ALL THESE YEARS WORKING
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS KIDS, THE
BIGGEST THING I SEE IS, PARENTS,
HOW DO WE HELP THE FAMILY? AND
WE HAVE A LOT OF MONEY, POMONA
HAS EIGHT ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
SITES GIVEN GRANTED GRANTS FOR
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS, THREE HIGH
SCHOOLS, I JUST FEEL THAT THE
MONEY IS NOT SPENT VERY WELL,
AND THEY ARE MEETING ONLY BASIC
NEEDS FOR OUR STUDENTS. HOWEVER,
WHERE ARE OUR PARENTS WHEN THESE
KIDS DISPLAY BEHAVIOR ISSUES? IT
COMES FROM THE HOME, AND WE
DON'T PROVIDE ENOUGH PARENT
EDUCATION. AND I KNOW YOU GUYS
TALKED ABOUT TRAINING TEACHERS
TRAINING TEACHERS ARE
OVERWHELMED. THEY ANYBODY CAN
PRETTY MUCH IDENTIFY A KID
HAVING ISSUES. THE KIDS THAT
WORK THERE ARE DISPLAYING ISSUE.
THEY ARE NOT EVEN DISPLAYING
LITTLE, YOU KNOW, BEHAVIOR
ISSUES. THEY'RE IN CRISIS. AND
SO BY THE TIME, THE TEACHERS
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH THEM,
AND WE HAVE A LOT, WE HAVE
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL COUNSELORS AT
EVERY SITE, BUT THOSE
COUNSELORS, YOU KNOW, THEY'RE
VERY SWEET, VERY, PROFESSIONAL,
BUT THEY ARE NOT EVEN TRAINED TO
DEAL WITH THOSE SITUATIONS
BECAUSE THEIR TRAINING. I'VE
GONE THROUGH THE TRAINING MYSELF
IS LIKE, OKAY, YOU SEE THE KIDS
FOR THERAPY, YOU KNOW, THEY
NEVER REALLY TALK ABOUT CRISIS.
AND SO I THINK WE REALLY NEED,
YOU KNOW, I HOPE THAT YOU CAN
HELP US MAYBE ADVOCATE FOR,
DIFFERENT KINDS OF, TRAININGS
FOR TEACHERS AND COUNSELORS AND
SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGISTS DURING THE,
THE SCHOOL, THEIR GRADUATE
SCHOOL OR THE SCHOOLING THAT
THEY DO. SO THAT'S MY COMMENT.
AND THANK YOU. THANK YOU, WELL,
JUST REAL QUICKLY, I JUST
REMEMBER MR. SISNEROS TALKING
ABOUT THE TRIPLE TRACKED
LEARNING, RIGHT WHERE YOU TAKE
THE EDUCATION AND YOU IMPLEMENT
IT WITH TEACHERS, PARENTS AND
STUDENTS ATTENDING, YOU KNOW,
HOLISTIC APPROACH. BUT LATER ON,
I WANT TO CONTINUE TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION. WE'RE RUNNING OUT
OF TIME, BUT I'M GOING TO PICK
YOUR BRAIN, MAKE SURE THAT WE
FIGURE OUT, IS IT POSSIBLE TO
IMPLEMENT IT STATEWIDE, AND HOW
CAN WE SUPPORT OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS SO THEY CAN FOLLOW
SUIT. SO I'M GOING TO TURN IT
OVER TO LORETTA. I THINK YOU HAD
A COMMENT. WE SAW THE SAME THING,
AND WE NOW ARE OFFERING ONLINE
COURSES, TO BEEF UP MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES, YOU KNOW, IN
SCHOOLS, INCLUDING CRISIS
RESPONSE, SUICIDE ASSESSMENTS
AND OTHER KINDS OF THINGS USING
TECHNIQUES LIKE MOTIVATIONAL
INTERVIEWING AND EVERYTHING LIKE
THAT. SO THE TRAINING AND SCHOOL
COUNSELORS HAS CHANGED OVER THE
YEARS. AND SO AND THAT'S
OVERSEEN BY THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING. AND SO
THOSE THINGS ARE HAPPENING AND,
AND TO GREATER DEGREES IN
REGARDS TO TRAINING. BUT THERE
ALSO NEEDS TO BE AN
UNDERSTANDING FROM
ADMINISTRATION TO ALLOW FOR
SUPPORT SERVICES, SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGISTS, SOCIAL WORKERS
AND COUNSELORS TO BE ABLE TO GET
OFF THE JOB FOR THE DAY TO GET
THE TRAINING. BECAUSE I HEAR IT
ALL THE TIME. THEY SAY, OH, I
CAN'T COME TO THE CONFERENCE. I
CAN'T COME TO THE TRAINING. SO
MUCH HAPPENS DURING THE DAY. SO
THEY DON'T ALLOW FOR FOLKS AWAY
BECAUSE THEY'RE SO VALUABLE, SO
THEY DON'T ALLOW FOR THEM TO GO
AND GET THE TRAINING THAT THEY
NEED TO STAY UP TO DATE WITH.
WHAT'S, THEIR PRACTICES AND
THEIR SCOPE OF PRACTICE. THANK
YOU. ANYBODY ELSE? LAST COMMENT?
YEAH. I WOULD JUST SAY LIKE THE
TRAIN, THE TRAINER MODELS I
THINK ARE VERY EFFECTIVE AS FAR
AS, LIKE YOU SAID, GETTING INTO
THE COMMUNITY. YOU KNOW, FINDING
A PARENT THAT FEELS JUST LIKE
YOU DO HAS JUST AS MUCH AMBITION
TO SEE THINGS CHANGE IN THEIR
COMMUNITY. AND MAYBE THEY BECOME
THAT RESIDENTIAL KIND OF
COMMUNITY EXPERT AND TRAIN THE
REST OF THE PARENTS, BECAUSE
SOMETIMES THOSE FAMILIES DON'T
WANT TO COME IN AND WORK WITH
THE SYSTEM OR THE, THE SCHOOL
SYSTEM, SO THEN I WOULD ALSO SAY
LEVERAGING TECHNOLOGY, I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF VIRTUAL,
ONLINE, SELF-PACED COURSES THAT
COULD BE DEVELOPED AROUND THAT
TRAIN. THE TRAINER MODEL. SO I
THINK THERE'S POTENTIAL, BUT
MAYBE THEY JUST HAVEN'T MADE IT
TO POMONA YET. CAN I ADD ONE
MORE THING? SURE, I ALSO WANT TO
MENTION THAT, WHENEVER POSSIBLE,
IT'S GREAT IF THE SCHOOLS CAN
TEACH THE PARENTS THE EXACT SAME
SKILLS THEY ARE TEACHING THEIR
STUDENTS. RIGHT. SO, THAT'S ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE DONE
WITH OUR SCHOOL SOCIAL WORKERS,
FUNDED THROUGH THE MENTAL HEALTH
STUDENT SERVICES ACT, WHO ARE IN
15 DIFFERENT DISTRICTS. SO WE
TEACH STUDENTS A CURRICULUM AND
THE CLASSROOM AND IN SMALL
GROUPS AND THEN WE HAVE PARENT
WORKSHOPS SO THAT THE PARENTS
CAN REINFORCE THOSE SKILLS.
BECAUSE I THINK WHEN YOU'RE AT
WHAT YOU MAY BE EXPERIENCING,
ARE PARENTS WHO REALLY WANT TO
HELP THEIR STUDENTS, BUT THEY
DON'T KNOW HOW THE SKILLS THAT
THEY HAVE OR THE TECHNIQUES
THEY'VE TRIED HAVE NOT WORKED.
AND SO THE MORE THAT WE CAN DO
TO TEACH THEM WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO TEACH OUR STUDENTS, SIMILAR
TO THAT TRIPLE TRACK. RIGHT, WE
WILL ALL BE MORE EFFECTIVE AND
THEY WILL, YOU KNOW, FEEL MORE
THAT THEY'RE SUPPORTING THEIR
CHILDREN BETTER AS WELL. COULD I
JUST COULD I JUST SAY ONE MORE
THING? AND ALSO LIKE WE'RE GOING
TO ASK WE WOULD ASK OUR PARENTS
OR OUR, OUR TEACHERS AND OUR
STUDENTS. I THINK ASKING THE
PARENTS WHAT THEY NEED IS WHERE
TO START INITIALLY, BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT THAT'S WHERE YOU'RE
GOING TO FIND OUT WHICH WAY TO
MOVE FORWARD. MAYBE JUST BEFORE
IMPLEMENTING SOMETHING. GREAT
COMMENTS. THANK YOU. AND, WE
HAVE TIME FOR ONE MORE GUEST.
AFTERNOON. AND THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME. I'M TONY ALVARADO
FROM THE ONTARIO MONTCLAIR
SCHOOL DISTRICT, AND I JUST WANT
TO GIVE YOU GUYS A SHOUT OUT,
REALLY HAPPY WITH EVERYTHING
THAT'S GOING ON, THE SCHOOL
CLIMATE IN OUR DISTRICT HAS
CHANGED. I'M AN ALUMNI OF OUR
SCHOOL, SO WHEN I WENT TO
SCHOOL, IT WAS VERY DIFFERENT
FROM WHEN MY CHILDREN GO TO
SCHOOL RIGHT NOW. AND, AS A
COMMUNITY MEMBER AND A LOT OF
THE STUFF THAT YOU GUYS SAID HAS
BEEN IMPLEMENTED IN OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND OUR SCHOOL CLIMATE
HAS CHANGED, AND EVERYBODY HAS
TO BUY IN AND BE THOSE LEADERS
IN THEIR COMMUNITY AND WORKING
TOGETHER. WE'RE ON OUR SECOND
ROUND OF COMMUNITY, SCHOOL,
COMMUNITY GRANTS, AND IT HAS
MADE A BIG DIFFERENCE FOR OUR
PARENTS, BEING PART OF OUR
SCHOOL. SO WE'RE NOT BLAMING THE
PARENTS FOR THEIR CHILD'S,
BEHAVIOR. WE'RE WORKING WITH
THEM BECAUSE, LIKE YOU SAID,
THEY'RE ALL KIDS. THEY ALL WANT
TO BE KIDS. THEY HAVE TO
EXPLORE. THEY MAKE MISTAKES, BUT
WE HAVE TO TELL THEM IT'S A
MISTAKE. IT'S NOT BECAUSE
THEY'RE BAD, I'VE BEEN SPEAKING
TO A COUPLE OF THE TEACHERS, AND
THEY SAY, WELL, KIDS DON'T WANT
TO BE SNITCHES. I GO, WELL,
THEY'RE NOT SNITCHES. YOU GOTTA
TELL THEM THEY'RE LEADERS.
LEADERS DON'T SNITCH. THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT YOU
SNITCH AND WHAT YOU. YOU TELL
THE KIDS WHAT IS BEING
LEADERSHIP. IF YOUR FRIEND TELLS
YOU I LIKE THIS GIRL. I LIKE
THIS BOY. THAT'S SNITCHING
BECAUSE THEY GAVE YOU SOMETHING
IN CONFIDENCE TO NOT GO AND TELL
THE WHOLE SCHOOL. BUT IF YOUR
PEER TELLS YOU, YOU KNOW THIS
KID HAS A KNIFE IN THEIR
BACKPACK OR MY DAD HAS A GUN, I
SHOULD BRING IT SO YOU GUYS
COULD SEE IT. THAT'S BEING A
LEADER TELLING AN ADULT
SOMETHING THAT COULD POTENTIALLY
CAUSE ANY HARM. SO IT'S JUST
MINDSET. WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON MINDSET. WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO FUND OUR SCHOOLS
WITH PARENT EDUCATION. WE HAVE
AN AWESOME PARENT LEADERSHIP
CONFERENCE EVERY YEAR. WE ADDED
TWO MORE DURING THE YEAR. AND WE
HAVE AN AWESOME PARENT CENTER
THAT WE, HELP OUR PARENTS, YOU
KNOW, AND TEACH THEM WHAT WE'RE
TEACHING AND TEACH THEM TO BE
LEADERS IN OUR COMMUNITY, TO
HELP OUR KIDS GROW IN OUR
COMMUNITY. SO I WOULD, YOU KNOW,
SAY, LET'S CONTINUE TO DO THAT
WORK AND KEEP GETTING THE
FUNDING FOR IT TO WORK AS A AS A
GROUP AND BE LEADERS IN OUR IN
OUR STATE. AWESOME. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WELL, THANK YOU ON THAT.
YOU KNOW, WE LEFT OFF ON A
POSITIVE NOTE AND I WANT TO JUST
THANK ALL OF YOU WHO CAME HERE
PERSONALLY TO JOIN US. IT WAS A
REALLY CRITICAL CONVERSATION
THAT WE NEEDED TO HAVE. AND
HOPEFULLY SOME OF YOU ARE GOING
BACK AND IMPLEMENTING SOME OF
THE STRATEGIES OR WHAT YOU HEARD
HERE IN YOUR OWN DISTRICTS, IN
YOUR OWN HOMES, WITH YOUR OWN
CHILDREN, AND WANT TO THANK ALL
OUR COLLEAGUES WHO COULD NOT BE
HERE, WHO ARE WATCHING REMOTELY,
AND ALL OUR GUESTS THAT ARE ALSO
WATCHING REMOTELY. AND THIS
CONCLUDES THE SENATE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON SCHOOL CLIMATE AND
STUDENT SAFETY. WE ARE
ADJOURNED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. THAT WAS
GOOD. THANK YOU.